[Musique]
depuis 5 ans Louise vient en aide au
plus démunis
chaque hiver elle leur procure de la
nourriture et un logement c'est d'autant
plus admirable que depuis 5 ans Louise
n'est plus parmi nous
par contre
[Musique]
faire un lag à la Fondation apprentie
d'Auteuil c'est permettre à des milliers
de jeunes de croire de nouveau à
l'avenir
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
sur public Senna ici en direct de la
Porte de Versailles à Paris pour la
première journée de ce Salon
International de l'Agriculture
aujourd'hui et toute la semaine
prochaine les équipes de Public Sénat
sont mobilisées pour vous faire vivre
cet événement la plus grande ferme de
France alors cet après-midi nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure et demie pour
évoquer les enjeux de ce salon de
l'agriculture et puis aussi pour suivre
la traditionnelle visite du président de
la République Emmanuel Macron qui a
inauguré ce matin l'événement il a
également rencontré les éleveurs de la
vache Ovalie l'égérie de ce salon cette
année une vache qui fait la fierté de la
race salaire en Auvergne et puis le
Président on a profité pour goûter aux
spécialités françaises qui montrent la
qualité de nos filières avec par exemple
des huîtres à l'heure du petit déjeuner
et puis Emmanuel Macron a évoqué les
nombreux enjeux les nombreux défis qui
se posent à notre agriculture cette
année avec une urgence à la sécheresse
une période de sécheresse record en ce
moment avec plus d'un mois sans
précipitations dans le tout le pays et
le président de la République a annoncé
un plan d'urgence pour lutter contre la
sécheresse on va l'écouter on a ces
derniers jours transmis au Conseil
d'État un décret pour mieux réutiliser
les eaux usées on doit mieux utiliser
nos eaux avoir moins de fuite préserver
justement les choses on doit mettre en
place les structures partout sur le
territoire pour permettre ces rétentions
colinéaires permettre aux agriculteurs
de fonctionner et la nation a besoin de
faire sur l'eau comme on l'a fait sur
l'énergie une forme de plantes sobriété
c'est à dire qu'on doit tous nous
citoyens
industriels services collectivités
locales et agriculteurs faire attention
à cette ressource qui deviendra c'est ce
que je disais en fin d'été c'est la fin
de l'abondance c'est donc faut qu'on
aille vers des comportements de sobriété
dans nos pratiques
et la sécheresse qui est parti des
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
qui frappent nos agriculteurs pour en
parler on va retrouver Quentin calmer
notre journaliste qui sillonne lui aussi
les allées du Salon de l'Agriculture et
Quentin cette sécheresse actuelle elle
fait partie elle fait partie des
inquiétudes de nos agriculteurs
à la fois elle est céréalière c'est
attendu mais aussi les éleveurs que l'on
croise ici dans le hall 1 ou était
Emmanuel Macron depuis 8 heures ce matin
écouter par exemple un éleveur à notre
micro puisque on le dit il y a de la
sécheresse dans le pays depuis l'été
dernier mais particulièrement en hiver
qui inquiète avec très peu de pluie pour
recharger les nappes phréatiques écouter
donc un éleveur
plein de sobriété effectivement il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se sortent qui
s'annoncent politiquement aujourd'hui
réellement il faut savoir il va falloir
savoir en priorité quels sont les
accompagnements qu'il va y avoir nous
dans nos départements on est des
départements où on ira aussi on a déjà
des restrictions d'eau donc
effectivement la sécheresse commence
très tôt on est qu'au mois de février 20
février donc je vais dire l'année
dernière ça a été compliqué cette année
si on a la sécheresse il commence en
février notamment sur nous exploitations
qui sont plus exploitations de
politiques plus élevage une partie
céréalière aussi mais la priorité c'est
aujourd'hui c'est de nous nourrir de nos
animaux donc si demain il y a
restriction d'eau que la canicule arrive
ça va être très compliqué à terme pour
nourrir nos animaux
d'ailleurs Alex à la prise en compte du
réchauffement climatique ça fait partie
des échanges qui a pu avoir le président
de la République avec certains Français
depuis les années de culture et
effectivement et bien Alex dans parmi
ces échanges on note un échange en
particulier assez où le avec un jeune
qui l'a interrogé écouter un extrait de
cet échange
on n'arrêtera pas parce que là on en a
on peut plus demander gentiment
monsieur prends ton dessin animé sinon
ça va être terrible tous les rapports
scientifiques pourquoi vous ne les
écoutez pas pourquoi
regarder ça pourquoi non
vous venez dans le gouffre des millions
si jamais on a si jamais vous ne faites
rien il y aura des gens qui ont en
prison on s'arrêtera pas il y aura rien
qui nous arrêtera j'ai fini ce que
j'avais à dire vous n'êtes pas résident
on vous a déjà entendu monsieur
vous êtes la démonstration vous avez
entendu
violence physique non il y a pas de
violence
vous nous pousser à bout sur
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
tous les états illégal monsieur
c'est pas un débat parti c'est pas un
débat c'est pas un débat vous annoncer
qu'on ne se laissera pas faire on ne
peut plus laisser faire nos vies qui
sont en jeu monsieur c'est nos vies qui
sont en jeu vous n'avez pas le courage
de la cohérence d'écouter une réponse
monsieur ça vous ressemble voilà un
extrait assez houleux en échange assez
houleux qui est qui impressionne par son
ton il y en a eu comme ça deux ou trois
dans la journée depuis 8h à l'arrivée du
président de la République mais au-delà
de ces quelques échanges à la visite se
passe dans le calme même s'il faut le
dire Alex il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
monde cette année dans les allées du
Salon de la Porte de Versailles
peut-être aussi parce que c'est la
première année où il n'y a plus de
crainte autour du covid ce qui explique
cette foule dans les allées cette année
et le retour des Français en masse au
salon de l'agriculture merci beaucoup
Quentin et on reviendra vers vous
régulièrement dans cette émission
notamment pour vivre cette visite du
président de la République alors pour
évoquer les enjeux de ce salon de
l'agriculture j'accueille sur ce plateau
Cristian Lambert bonjour
président de la FNSEA le 1er syndicat
agricole français j'accueille également
François Patriat bonjour bonjour vous
êtes président du groupe RDPI au Sénat
le groupe de la majorité présidentielle
bonjour Pascal perrineo vous êtes
politologue professeur émérite des
universités à Sciences Po et ancien
directeur du sevipov le centre de
recherche de Sciences Po et puis
j'accueille Fabienne gomant bonjour
bonjour vous êtes directrice adjointe du
pôle opinion à l'Ifop avant de parler de
la sécheresse qui est une vraie
inquiétude pour les agriculteurs je
voudrais vous faire réagir à cet échange
très tendu qu'on a vu entre un militant
écologiste et le président de la
République Cristiano Lambert je vous ai
vu réagir pendant la diffusion de cette
séquence ça vous regrettez ce type
d'échange ce type de tension c'est pas
un échange
c'est pas un échange il hurle il n'y a
pas de réponse c'est happening c'est une
punchline mais il n'attendait pas de
réponse il voulait hurler et être filmé
est-ce que c'est ça qu'on a besoin dans
notre pays il faut s'écouter d'abord
pour se comprendre et puis qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait ce jeune pourquoi il dit ça
sur quoi il s'engage pour que ça change
moi je suis engagée pour ça change ici
vous avez des gens qui sont engagés en
politique des gens qui enseignent je
suis mère de famille moi-même j'ai des
enfants qui ont 3 31 et 23 ans je ne
leur dis pas à les hurler dans un micro
je leur ai engagez-vous je crois que
c'est un sujet de société mais je pense
que le politologue en parlera mieux que
moi François Patriat comment vous
réagissez à ce type d'altercation entre
le Président de la République et ce
militant écologiste qui visiblement ne
voulait pas dialoguer depuis ce matin
j'ai suivi le président de la République
au cours de toute la déambulation depuis
le moment où il a coupé le ruban
jusqu'au moment où il vient d'arriver au
stand viticole où je l'ai quitté à
l'instant
trouver un président qui était très
engagé sur les causes qui apporte des
réponses précises qui montrent sa
volonté de se défendre deux choses la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France sa
capacité exportatrice à côté et soutenir
le monde agricole auquel il est très
attaché là vous avez dans le salon le
risque quand vous acceptez une
déambulation au milieu de tout le monde
sans qu'il y ait des gens devant qui
forment le chemin au risque toujours
d'avoir quelqu'un qui parle outrance par
l'excès et là pour vous inviter parce
qu'effectivement Christiane avait raison
ça fait l'image ça fait bien ça fait
réussir maintenant sur l'eau le sujet
est réel le sujet est réel parce que
tout le monde pas seulement le monde
agricole mais je pense que l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques de ce pays on va
en parler dans quelques-uns donc sur la
sur l'eau je crois que le gouvernement a
déjà apporté des réponses et des mesures
qui sont prises on a d'autres qui sont
en cours et pour lesquelles nous
discutons aujourd'hui avec la profession
agricole on va parler dans quelques
instants de cette question de la
sécheresse mais Pascal Perrineau
finalement c'est un peu le retour
d'Emmanuel Macron dans la foule face aux
Français et on le voit il peut être
confronté finalement aux tensions de
société notamment sur cette question
écologique et du réchauffement
climatique oui mais ça n'est pas le
premier président de la République qui
se fait interpeller dans le salon de
l'agriculture ou ailleurs voilà ça fait
partie ça fait partie du jeu cependant
la manière dont ce jeune militant
s'adresse au président de la République
et tout à fait symptomatique de un
phénomène beaucoup plus large chez la
dégradation du débat public on l'a vu à
l'Assemblée nationale avec le
comportement de certains
jeunes députés on le voit avec ce
militant écologiste qui d'une radicalité
où l'on écoute plus l'autre on n'écoute
pas l'adversaire l'adversaire est un
ennemi c'est celui qu'il faut abattre et
donc il le dit d'ailleurs je ne veux pas
débattre quand on en arrive là il faut
vraiment s'inquiéter parce que la
démocratie si on arrive à être
définition très simple c'est le débat
institutionnalisé le débat avec ceux
avec lesquels nous ne sommes pas en
accord mais avec lesquels on tente de
trouver un compromis et là on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a dans certains secteurs de la
société française des tensions un revu
du débat et pour ce qui concerne
l'écologie vous savez on est au salon de
l'agriculture l'écologie politique et
l'écologie militante c'est une force
urbaine beaucoup plus qu'une force
rurale au plan électoral quand vous
regardez c'est le monde rural regarde
parfois ces militants avec un une
certaine distance c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et puis il y a deux
écologies il y a l'écologie qui cherche
les issus pratiques qui cherchent à
améliorer les équilibres et puis il y a
une écologie que les Allemands appellent
l'écologie fondamentaliste qui a qui
prend des allures parfois de religion de
mysticisme c'est une écologie
complètement apocalyptique on a
l'impression en effet que demain le
monde va disparaître et ce jeune est
certainement porteurs de cette
conception de l'écologie et il y a
urgence pour les forces de gouvernement
qu'elle soit deux droites de gauche ou
d'ailleurs de faire exister
véritablement une écologie du
gouvernement une écologie de la raison
Fabienne Gaumont ce type d'échange se
militantisme écologique ça a un illustre
pas l'opinion publique et d'agriculture
on va parler d'un cultures
oui oui juste une réaction
s'il vous plaît bien sûr que non mais
juste une réaction est-ce que ça
illustre ce qu'il y a dans l'opinion
publique c'est à dire une tension autour
de la question de du réchauffement
climatique alors je voulais justement me
prendre aussi Perrino effectivement elle
le ce qui est apparu là n'est pas une
sorte de happening effectivement et dont
il est pas du tout représentatif de
l'opinion en tout cas globale des
Français qui qui illustre peut-être une
forme de colère on ne connaît pas les
motivations de de ce personnage donc ça
illustre peut-être une forme de colère
mais effectivement il y a des conditions
de des conditions du débat ne sont plus
ne se retrouvent plus facilement
aujourd'hui dans dans le dans l'opinion
en revanche on en parlera je suppose un
petit peu après l'opinion majoritaire
qui domine par rapport à l'agriculture
elle est très largement positive et
c'est pas du tout cette cette
illustration qui pourrait se révéler
représentative de ce qui se passe dans
la population et bien sûr avec un
chiffre quelle image avez-vous de
l'agriculture française c'est une
question que votre institut Ifop a posé
et bien aux Français et 76% des Français
ont une image positive de l'agriculture
française Cristiano Lambert on va parler
des vrais sujets qui se posent à la
culture cette année notamment de la
sécheresse on a attendu on a entendu le
président de la République qui a annoncé
un plan spécial pour la sécheresse pour
une meilleure utilisation de l'eau
comment vous réagissez à ce plan est-ce
que ça vous inquiète car les
agriculteurs ont besoin de cette
ressource en eau le président de la
République a commencé en disant qu'il
fallait arrêter toutes les fuites d'eau
des canalisations 20% de l'eau qui part
d'une source n'arrive pas à destination
des utilisateurs parce qu'il y a des
fuites d'eau partout déjà arrêté ses
fuites deuxième chose constater que pour
l'agriculture l'eau ça sert à faire
l'alimentation donc c'est pas de l'eau à
qui apparaît c'est de l'eau pour que
vous puissiez manger des fruits et
légumes des tomates du pain etc et cette
eau là elle est essentielle la France
est un des pays où il y a le moins de
stockage d'eau savez-vous qu'aujourd'hui
il y a plus de stockage bonne marque au
Pays-Bas qui sont pourtant plus hauts
que nous en latitude parce qu'ils ont
compris que le changement climatique
faisait l'alternance de période très
sèches et des périodes très pluvieuses
donc faut stocker les eaux diluviennes
faut aussi faire le constat que sur la
dernière décennie la quantité d'eau
reçue à baissée de 14 %, oui c'est vrai
qu'il y a un tassement de la
pluviométrie reçue il y a plus de
violence quand elle arrive on a vu
beaucoup d'images d'inondations
dramatiques donc stocker quand elle est
abondante il faut aussi se poser la
question de la sobriété quant aux usages
est-ce normal qu'on puisse construire
des piscines 10 dans la même commune
sans autorisation particulière c'est à
l'infini aller plus vite sur la
réutilisation de l'eau quand on tire sa
chasse d'eau en tant que vous quand je
tire ma chasse d'eau c'est un pack d'eau
9 litres d'eau ni directement
à la poubelle mais sans récupération
toutes ces questions de la réutilisation
de l'eau de la sobriété elle est
extrêmement importante et un agriculture
nous avons réduit de 30% l'eau nous
avons
pas nécessaire pour faire une tonne de
blé c'est à dire qu'on a amélioré
l'efficience de l'eau parce qu'on mesure
l'humidité du sol le besoin de la plante
les vapo transpiration avec des capteurs
et des technologies qui permettent
d'être d'avoir une utilisation plus
sobre donc poursuivre le varen de l'eau
a-t-il dit tant mieux stocker de l'eau
parce que c'est l'alimentation et parce
que c'est phénomènes d'alternance
sécheresse inondations vont certainement
se répéter et on aura toujours besoin de
ces grandes réserves d'eau notamment
formées en hiver ce qu'on appelle les
méga bassines et que certains
écologistes dénoncent on se rappelle les
manifestations à l'automne dernier à
Sainte Soline dans les Deux Sèvres
contre un nouveau projet de mégabassie
c'est un phénomène franco-fensé de
radicalité je veux pas donc je casse
même des élus de la République qui
vendent des manifestations interdites
quand même c'est on est très français là
le Berry il faut le ranger très vite
ces réserves d'eau elles ont été faites
avec des autorisations gouvernementales
et c'est la préfète c'est-à-dire
l'autorité préfectorale qui décide du
remplissage de ces réserves quand les
sols sont saturés
les règles franco-françaises ça ne
serait pas très sérieux ma boussole
c'est la souveraineté alimentaire
comment produire en France conserver des
agriculteurs du revenu et de
l'alimentation pour les Français les
Européens et on va évoquer ce sujet de
la souveraineté alimentaire François
patriars sur la sécheresse le défi du
président de la République c'est à la
fois de faire preuve de sobriété face à
une ressource qui manque et en même
temps de donner aux agriculteurs et bien
les conditions avec cette ressource pour
produire je veux dire les difficultés
que nous rencontrons sur le terrain en
milieu rural souvent c'est que nous
avons souvent des difficultés à mettre
en place des solutions simples par
exemple les retenues colinaires nous
avons aujourd'hui les phénomènes
cévenols qui se reproduisent de plus en
plus avec des chutes d'eau très
abondantes à des moments donnés et des
périodes de sécheresse même Lambert
vient de dire à l'instant il faut
pouvoir à ces endroits créer des
retenues colinaires pour stocker local
et l'arrêt de dynamique quand on en a
besoin or vous savez que aujourd'hui
tant les difficultés que nous avons avec
les administrations je le dis avec bien
entendu les environnements talistes ici
opposent aujourd'hui même y compris la
loi sur sur laquelle moi j'aimerais
qu'on revienne aujourd'hui la loi sur
l'eau qui a supprimé tous les barrages
qui dit que pour aujourd'hui que les
cours d'eau suivent alors que nos
anciens avaient fait des stockages d'eau
qui existaient qu'on fait disparaître
aujourd'hui des moulins des étangs qu'on
peut pas mettre en eau là il y a une
vraie difficulté pour laquelle nous
devons répondre aujourd'hui et je me
fais moi-même le reproche de ne pas y
arriver assez vite ensuite sur la
sobriété vous avez compris quand vous
avez de l'eau potable on a du mal à
produire et que les deux tirs de l'eau
potable elle passe dans les toilettes
dans la vaisselle dans les machines à
laver alors qu'on pourrait l'utiliser
autrement qu'on ne sait pas vraiment
encore de façon quand on construit
récupérer l'autre pluie qu'on ne sait
pas retraiter les eaux usées on voit
bien qu'il y a des pistes tout ça repose
aujourd'hui j'y ajoute maintenant
l'agriculture qui a besoin d'eau qui
ajoute en même temps la recherche et la
recherche d'importante sur la production
de céréales et de production qui ont
moins besoin d'eau aujourd'hui sur
laquelle il faut que nous travaillons
effectivement aussi beaucoup Pascal
Perrineau on a entendu le président de
la République il a répété hein c'est la
fin de l'abondance de l'abondance comme
il l'avait dit en 2022 ça s'inscrit dans
un discours présidentielle qui a changé
en ce début de quinquennat il parlait à
des amis dans le premier quinquennat et
là il dit c'est la fin de la récré la
fin d'abondance bien sûr bien sûr mais
c'est pas simplement une prise de
conscience du président de la République
la prise de conscience vous savez le
changement le changement ça peut être à
la fois changement d'en haut et on voit
les Français attendent beaucoup du
président de la République quitte à
l'interpellé avec excessivement de
vigueur on attend des politiques
publiques il y a qu'à faudrait une loi
etc mais il y a aussi le changement d'en
bas c'est à dire notre changement le
changement des citoyens et avoir des
comportements plus vertueux ça ne
dépendra pas du président de la
République d'une loi
et des politiques publiques ça dépendra
de nous et là il y a sur ce terrain sur
ce dossier de l'eau un gâchis
gigantesque si les Français ne prennent
pas en main ce changement je crains que
dans trois quatre ans on est exactement
le même débat avec les mines peut-être
encore un peu plus triste qu'aujourd'hui
donc il y a un changement individuel à
avoir qui est tout à fait décisive une
prise de conscience
collective les acteurs du changement et
là si vous voulez on est en France en
France on attend tout d'en haut on
attend toutes les tas et du chef de
l'État maintenant attendons un peu de
nous-même et de l'inflexion du
changement de nos comportements allez on
va voir avec quels sont les enjeux
généraux de ce salon de l'agriculture
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique sur nos exploitations en font
partie mais il y a aussi la souveraineté
alimentaire vous l'avez évoqué
Christiane Lambert notamment les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine le
bouleversement des marchés agricoles la
hausse des prix on fait le point avec
Fabien Ricard
la ferme France sous le feu des
projecteurs jusqu'au 5 mars impacté par
le changement climatique et la guerre en
Ukraine les agriculteurs français ont
des messages à faire passer aux
politiques attendus dans les travées du
salon c'est un temps fort que
l'agriculture française a besoin déjà
pour expliquer ce qu'elle fait ensuite
pour expliquer ces problèmes et ensuite
pour qu'on l'aide à lui tracer des voies
d'avenir un avenir lourd d'incertitude
en raison d’abord de la guerre qui
oppose deux géants agricoles la Russie
et l'Ukraine la flambée des cours des
céréales a pu bénéficier aux céréaliers
français mais a durement touché les
éleveurs faisant exploser les coups de
l'alimentation pour leurs animaux des
éleveurs déjà frappés par la hausse du
coût de l'énergie ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à jeter l'éponge la guerre
en Ukraine a enfin révélé la forte
dépendance européenne aux engrais
azotées russes autres chantiers
sensibles la question des
phytosanitaires et en particulier des
néonicotinoïdes un pesticides tueurs d'A
interdit en France depuis 2018 seuls les
betteraviers bénéficiaient d’une
dérogation depuis deux ans mais celle-ci
a pris fin c'est une erreur grave parce
que d'autres pays européens n'ont pas
fait le même choix et aujourd'hui ils
vont produire des betteraves avec des
produits interdits chez nous et nous
importeront leur sucre est-ce que c'est
ça qu'on veut en France non donc je
crois qu'il faut être sérieux tant qu'il
y a pas de solution il faut pouvoir
garder les dérogations pour pouvoir les
utiliser autre sujet crucial la gestion
de l'eau le Salon de l'Agriculture ouvre
ses portes alors que la sécheresse en
France bas des records de précocité le
gouvernement promet 37 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau supplémentaires pour
l'agriculture cet été grâce à de
nouveaux ouvrages hydrauliques en jeu
garantir la souveraineté alimentaire de
la France en 2030
Fabienne Gaumont on l'a vu dans ce sujet
la souveraineté alimentaire et notamment
les conséquences de la guerre de la
guerre en Ukraine sur notre agriculture
c'est une vraie inquiétude pour nos
agriculteurs avec une envolée des cours
et des coûts pour les exploitations mais
du côté des Français les Français ont
toujours confiance dans la capacité du
pays à nourrir sa population oui la
recette qu'on voit dans le sondage qu'on
a pu mener en fin d'année c'est que si
Français sur dix ont confiance en la
capacité de la France à produire de quoi
nourrir sa population donc c'est un
score qui est majoritaire mais bon il y
a quand même quatre Français sur 10 qui
sont quand même un peu inquiets par
rapport à cette capacité donc ça demeure
pour autant le lien il est pas forcément
fait entre le français il raisonne en
tant que consommateur avant de raisonner
en tant que citoyen et donc c'est par sa
consommation qu'il va juger de de alors
de de cette souveraineté alimentaire
mais aussi de qui va
cette consommation va aussi comment dire
correspond à sa capacité d'action en
fait et sa capacité de changement comme
en parler monsieur Perino à l'instant et
donc c'est à travers sa consommation
qu'il va pouvoir agir et manifester ce
ses inquiétudes et c'est souhaits et en
ça on peut reboucler avec la trait que
les français portent aux produits locaux
à ce qui est d'origine locale ça fait
partie de ces parmi les attentes
prioritaires des Français en fait en
termes de de critères d'achat on a en
tout premier la qualité mais en seconde
le local et le local c'est quelque chose
qui a pris de l'ampleur à la suite de la
crise sanitaire et qui est de plus en
plus demandé qui plus est lorsqu'on
parle de Made in France et notamment
parce que donc ça a pris de l'ampleur à
la suite de la crise sanitaire puisque
pour des questions de disponibilité des
produits et puis ça c'est accentué avec
les événements qui se déroulent en
Ukraine aujourd'hui les Français
attachés aux produits locaux et
Christian Lambert on le voit il y a une
hausse des importations sur certains
produits certaines filières Cristian
Lambert est-ce que la souveraineté
alimentaire de la France est menacée
aujourd'hui oui oui les menacées c'est
pour ça que nous tirons vraiment la
sonnette d'alarme nous avons augmenté
toutes nos importations c'est un comble
parce que jamais la souveraineté
alimentaire n'a été autant évoquée dans
les médias etc il y a même le libellé
dans le titre du ministère de
l'agriculture mais l'agriculture
française dévisse nous perdons des
volumes de production avec les vaches
allaitantes avec le lait avec le porc
avec les pommes avec les cerises c'est
dramatique on a vraiment moi j'ai mis
sous les yeux du président de la
République mercredi lors d'une rencontre
à l'Elysée toutes les courbes de
production elles sont dirigées vers le
bas il faut s'inquiéter lorsque vous
étiez ministre de l'Agriculture monsieur
Patriat nous étions dans une situation
plus favorable il y a 25 ans quand
j'étais président des Jeunes
Agriculteurs nous avions 14 milliards
d'euros d'excédents dans la balance
commerciale aujourd'hui nous sommes à 6
milliards seulement les autres pays
foncent la population mondiale augmente
les pays se disent on va produire pour
nourrir et nous en France depuis 25 les
seuls horizons pour la politique
agricole c'est plus d'environnement
alors oui il faut faire de
l'environnement mais ça ne doit pas
obéir la capacité à produire lors de la
cop21 il a été dit lutter contre le
changement climatique et en même temps
produire pour nourrir les populations
sinon famille migration et on sait les
problèmes que ça pose donc il faut
sonner le réveil des jeunes éleveurs
aujourd'hui qui vont s'installer ont
besoin de revenus de qualité de vie et
de reconnaissance alors le changement
qui vient d'en haut et d'en bas j'aime
beaucoup cette formule il a été dit
pendant plein d'années bio bio bio un
salon convertissant en bio les Français
veulent du bio que se passe-t-il nous
avons un effondrement de la consommation
bio moins 20% sur certains produits on
est en train de demander un plan de
soutien pour les agriculteurs en bio
pourquoi parce que il y a le citoyen qui
dit je veux je veux mais le consommateur
qui n'achète qu'avec son porte-monnaie
et qui nous Nord pas la commande donc
comme vous connaissez la formule citoyen
de bon matin et puis consommateur passer
le quart d'heure sauf que quand ils
achètent plus bio le rayon se rétrécit
et les producteurs bio n'ont pas de
débouchés donc faut aussi de la
cohérence mais un changement positif et
pour Monsieur Perrineau à cause du
changement climatique les agriculteurs
d'attente à une loi ils ont déjà changé
leur culture on a plus 6 % de culture
d'hiver parce que les agriculteurs se
sont dit gentils au cas où on est une
année sécheresse donc ça c'est du
changement qui fait pas de bruit
personne en parle et ce sont les
agriculteurs qui le font et tout ça nous
l'avons fait enseigné dans un ouvrage
qui est ici où on montre et ça sera mon
dernier chiffre en 15 ans on a réduit de
23% l'impact gaz à effet de serre d'un
litre de lait on l'a fait sans faire de
bruit donc les agriculteurs sont
vraiment en train de faire tous ces
changements dans leur ferme
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique François Patriat quand on
écoute le cri d'alarme que lance
Christian Lambert on voit qu'il y a un
défi encore amener pour la majorité
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron c'est de
concilier à la fois les besoins des
consommateurs en période
sur le bio est-il normal aujourd'hui que
des gens qui ont fait des efforts à la
fois de reconversion d'environnement de
productivités vendent du blé bio qui
produit trois fois ma cabel normal au
moitié moins soit vendu au même prix
qu'abi est normal c'est ça aujourd'hui
les gens qui se sont convertis en bio ma
crainte c'est que des gens qui ont fait
du bio il y a un ou deux ans pendant 2
ou 3 ans ils attendent des aides ils
touchent les aides ces aides vont te
diminution j'ai peur que dans 5 ans il
revienne c'est à dire qu'on aura fait
tous schéma pour rien on n'aura pas fait
dans le même temps mais pourtant quand
je viens ici au salon et j'y viens tous
les ans depuis des décennies je vois
qu'il y a un attachement des Français à
leur agriculture qui lui refond
confiance qui sont fiers d'une
agriculture que par ailleurs il défie au
nom de principes souverains
d'environnement qui sont excessifs par
ailleurs je crois que là quand le
superinaud dit en haut et en bas il est
dans le juste milieu parce qu'il dit
effectivement nous devons l'agriculture
fait les efforts des normes d'efforts
aujourd'hui de diminution je prends un
exemple aussi important on parle de la
betterave moi je suis dégoût d'un
département qui fait de la moutarde la
moutarde de Dijon et la moutarde tous
les crucifères la moutarde et le colza
le colza aujourd'hui vous avez vu
l'importance qu'il y a notamment avec
l'Ukraine on s'aperçoit que dans les
territoires comme le mien il n'y a plus
de production de colza aujourd'hui parce
qu'il n'y a plus de traitement possible
et qu'on a supprimé le traitement avant
même d'avoir trouvé les solutions de
remplacer
cette suppression des produits
phytosanitaires pour traiter la moutarde
a conduit à expatrier la moutarde au
Canada canicule au Canada plus de
moutarde et donc les Français pendant 6
mois ont entendu la moutarde et quand
les jours de l'Isle me disaient mais
quand est-ce qu'on aura de la moutarde
mais monsieur c'est une culture annuelle
ce qui veut dire que c'est fragile
l'agriculture mais interdire des
produits traitement en France alors
qu'ils sont autorisés ailleurs c'est une
aberration la France
nous venons la France Vienne interdire
trois produits phytos d'un goût qui sont
autorisés ailleurs et on va importer les
produits
phytosanitaires notamment des néon
juste avant de vous libérer un mot sur
cette réalité la consommation de
produits bio est en chute libre en ce
moment alors que selon vos enquêtes et
bien les Français sont attachés à une
alimentation de qualité locale comment
on commence à s'expliquer il y a aussi
la dimension pouvoir d'achat oui bien
sûr alors effectivement le bio
on le voit aussi dans nos enquêtes a été
subi aujourd'hui une sorte de désamour
par rapport à ce produit là et ça a
laissé la place à un très beau plus fort
pour le local qui lui semble dans les
représentations en tout cas rassembler
toutes les vertus aux yeux des Français
que ce soit sanitaire notamment alors
qu'on aurait pu s'attendre à ce que ce
soit le bio qui soit valorisé il a été
bien sûr et il le reste d'une certaine
façon mais en tout cas d'un point de vue
sanitaire on sait où les produits on a
l'impression de savoir où les produits
sont sont fabriqués des vertus
écologiques puisque les produits font
moins de kilomètres des vertus de
patriotiques des vertus
social avec des lentilles sociales parce
qu'en plus la vermine rémunération plus
directe des producteurs donc aux yeux
des Français ça rassemble tout et ça
permet de résoudre un peu son équation
mentale pour trouver le produit qui va
nous intéresser on n'est pas en train de
dire que demain tout le monde va
consommer local bien entendu et
effectivement il y a de façon très très
caricaturale deux orientations il y a la
population qui va être avoir peu de
difficultés financière et avoir les
moyens de mettre ces pratiques au
diapason de ces aspirations et puis tout
le courant qui va davantage acheter avec
ce qu'il y a dans le porte-monnaie et
avec ses possibilités mais les
aspirations elles demeure en fait mais
elle demeure globale tout le monde
n'aura pas les possibilités de de s'y
accorder et merci beaucoup à Fabienne
Gaumont d'être venu aujourd'hui sur le
plateau de publicainage rappelle que
vous êtes directrice adjointe du pôle
opinion de l'institut
Ifop vous parliez de cette attrait des
Français pour la consommation locale de
produits de circuits courts notamment je
voudrais qu'on écoute un extrait de la
visite du président de la République
aujourd'hui au salon agriculture sur
l'origine des viandes qui sont asservies
dans la restauration collective vous
allez voir c'est très intéressant 70
elle n'est pas française et les gars
elle vient pas de du bout du monde
néerlandaise bon ça c'est quand même
organisation à nous c'est pas le
Mercosur 70 % environ
une organise des restaurants on doit
transformer différemment faire moins de
hachis valoriser faire moins de gros
tard qu'on envoie c'est engraisser
ailleurs
si on s'est organisé la filière on sait
la valoriser on a les débouchés chinois
c'est notre c'est notre problème
d'organisation collective et aussi que
on sert dans nos restaurants de la
viande qui est européenne mais pas
française il y a rien qui m'impose mais
voilà 70% de la viande qui est servi
dans la restauration collective en
France n'est pas française et souvent
d'origine européenne Cristiano Lambert
une réaction sur ce chiffre qui est
quand même assez étonnant oui et ça
s'aggrave la seule qualité de la viande
étrangère a servi dans les cantines vous
la connaissez c'est qu'elle est moins
chère et donc quand les cantines les
restaurants mais les restaurants
d'entreprise les hôpitaux etc veulent ne
consacrer que 1,40 de coût matière à la
fabrication des repas voilà ce à quoi ça
aboutit voilà pourquoi nous nous avons
travaillé avec tous les acteurs de la
restauration collective pour montrer
l'intérêt d'acheter des produits
français
mais il faut aussi que les politiques
quand les conseils régionaux lorsqu'ils
en ont la responsabilité les conseils
départementaux expliquent aussi que
mettre un euro 40 ça suffit pas qu'il
faut peut-être mettre 1,60 à 0,70 vous
savez l'alimentation c'est le premier
facteur de santé famille rurale vient
sortir une enquête très intéressante
donner un chèque alimentaire au plus
démunis ça coûterait 7 milliards la
facture santé de la France c'est 21
milliards les problèmes de santé ils
sont très souvent beaucoup ils sont
souvent liés à des problèmes de mauvaise
alimentation ou déséquilibres de
l'alimentation regardez l'obésité qui va
crescendo c'est parce que les produits
trop sucrés trop salés le pas cher le
low cost n'a pas les qualités requises
nous nous travaillons sur l'éducation à
l'alimentation mardi nous signerons un
manifeste pour qu'il y ait une heure
d'éducation à l'alimentation dans les
écoles parce que ça commence par la
l'alimentation c'est la santé et ne pas
consacrer son budget à l'alimentation
c'est aussi à ne pas prioriser sa santé
c'est pour ça que pour l'instant on
appelle au consommateur nous incriminons
pas les consommateurs nous nous disons
soyons sérieux mangeons français c'est
un petit peu plus cher mais comme disent
beaucoup de personnes moi je préfère
savoir ce que je mange plutôt que de
faire venir des produits d'ailleurs qui
ont traité avec des produits chimiques
interdits chez nous c'est une belle
tromperie quand même et pour continuer à
parler de la souveraineté française
j'accueille sur ce plateau un autre
syndicat agricole la Confédération
paysanne bonjour Nicolas Géraud bonjour
vous êtes porte-parole de la
Confédération paysanne quand on entend
ce chiffre donné par Emmanuel Macron 70%
de la viande servie dans les restaurants
d'entreprises ou dans les cantines elle
n'est pas française ça vous inquiète et
ça participe de et bien cette inquiétude
vis-à-vis de la souveraineté oui très
clairement c'est c'est un chiffre
totalement inquiétant qui est pas
forcément nouveau mais j'allais dire qui
s'aggrave et qui pourrait encore
s'aggraver on est dans une logique de
libre-échange au niveau européen au
niveau mondial également on est toujours
dans une logique de rechercher le prix
le plus bas pour pour notre consommation
alimentaire et un moment donné comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour
cesser ce cercle vicieux là c'est en
tout cas pas en allant chercher de
nouveaux contingents contingentement de
comme de nouveaux volumes de viande
bovine notamment avec le Mercosur c'est
pas ça qui va nous permettre de bâtir
notre souveraineté alimentaire pour
bâtir notre souveraineté alimentaire
très clairement il va falloir du revenu
il va falloir des paysannes et des
paysans nombreux et il va falloir de la
protection économique pour ces paysans
et ses paysans c'est-à-dire arrêter de
livrer au libre-échange les paysannes
les paysans un autre chiffre qu'on a
régulièrement qu'elle met régulièrement
mis en avant c'est nos importations de
fruits et légumes en France on était
souverain dans les années 2000 en fruits
et légumes aujourd'hui on importe 50% de
nos fruits et légumes c'est à dire que
cette souveraineté alimentaire on est en
train de forcément la perdre on n'a
jamais réussi à la construire
complètement pourquoi parce qu'on est
dans une logique de marché libre et non
faussé et que il y a des importations
déloyales car il notamment d'Espagne ou
des Pays-Bas et ça c'est une logique
c'est une logique qui a été portée par
les politiques publiques et qu'il va
falloir un moment donné déconstruire
parce que si on est toujours dans cette
logique là on va ne faire que de mettre
à mal les agriculteurs et les et les
agricules Françaises parce qu'elles
Perrineau on avait l'image quand même de
la France comme une grande puissance
agricole une des premières puissances
européennes et en réalité cette
puissance elle est en train de
s'effriter
je ne sais pas je laisse au spécialiste
il faut pas être excessif la France
reste encore une des grandes puissances
agroalimentaires je regardais ça
récemment
on a souvent une vision un peu
misérabiliste vous savez quand on ne
connaît pas le monde agricole vu de
l'extérieur et on dit de toute façon les
agriculteurs ça n'est plus grand chose
dans la population active etc quand vous
regardez l'ensemble agroalimentaire en
France c'est je crois à peu près je
parle souvent de contrôle 15% de la
population active donc c'est à la fois
voilà une force j'allais dire dans cette
France de l'activité professionnelle et
au plan national et international la
France reste une grande puissance
agricole simplement on le voit bien et
la question de la souveraineté
aujourd'hui et c'est pas simplement
d'ailleurs sur le terrain alimentaire la
question de la souveraineté revient au
cœur de notre problématique et autour de
la souveraineté alimentaire on voit très
bien comment un projet de
repositionnement des agriculteurs
français au cœur de la société française
pour réussir cette souveraineté
alimentaire peut-être extrêmement
mobilisateur parce que les Français même
quand ils ne sont plus agriculteurs il y
en a pas en effet c'est
en dessous de nettement de 10% dans la
population active mais tous les Français
à deux générations il reste branché avec
le monde agricole et ça c'est quelque
chose de très différent par rapport à
l'essentiel de nos voisins européens qui
sont de très vieilles civilisations
urbaine nous on est une au fond une
civilisation urbaine assez neuve et oui
les Français sont attachés à leur
agriculture Christiane Lambert est-ce
que cette perte de souveraineté
alimentaire de la France elle est aussi
due à des normes environnementales trop
stricts en France par rapport à d'autres
pays qui partagent un marché et je
prends l'exemple de la polémique
actuelle sur les néonicotinoïdes qui
vont être interdits ça y est pour les
cultures de betteraves sous la pression
notamment de de l'Union européenne
toutes ces normes ça et bien diminue
notre production oui je crois que alors
même si ça nous fait mal au cœur de le
dire la France était le premier pays
exportateur et les 6e aujourd'hui donc
nous régressons et c'est désolant alors
que nous avons des sols du savoir-faire
des agriculteurs des industries de la
recherche nous avons tout pour réussir
mais il y a quand même quelque chose
changement donc on va pas parler que de
ce qui est noir des entreprises
aujourd'hui comme métro augmentent la
part de viande française de français de
les Français dans ce qu'ils offrent au
restaurant Les Maîtres restaurateurs qui
est une association avec un label
reconnu zoom sur
l'approvisionnement français McDonald's
qui a longtemps été incriminé pour son
approvisionnement est en train de faire
un tour de force de production pour
remettre plus de français dans ces
rayons les distributeurs par contre eux
n'ont pas toujours joué le jeu mais
certains d'entre eux jouent le jeu c'est
de cette façon là que nous arrivons à
reconquérir mais rajoutons que dans la
compétition de l'alimentation mondiale
puisque Poutine a fait de l'aliment une
arme de guerre j'ai la main sur le blé
les pays qui ne font pas les gens à la
Russie n'auront pas de blé moralité que
font-ils aujourd'hui se tourne vers la
France il nous avait abandonné parce que
notre blé était trop cher celui de
Poutine des témoins chers mais le jour
il coupe le robinet pour pas avoir faim
et avoir des émeutes c'est chez nous qui
reviennent et les Africains nous disent
mais les Français les Européens ne
désarment pas produisaient nous avons
besoin de vos céréales alors la première
règle pour pouvoir produire c'est
d'avoir les moyens de production c'est
ce que nous avons dit dans nos
manifestations pour voir avoir accès à
l'eau je note avec satisfaction que le
Président de la République a dit il
fallait plus d'eau pour produire de
l'alimentation en France tant mieux on
va restaurer les ouvrages hydrauliques
pour pouvoir les utiliser mieux je note
avec satisfaction que ce matin le
président de la République a dit sur les
produits phytosanitaires pas
d'interdiction tant qu'on n'a pas de
solution moi j'ai proposé une
planification des alternatives on passe
au tamis tous les produits
phytosanitaires il pose un problème OK
sous combien de temps on est capable de
trouver une solution quitte à réduire
les doses et quand on a des alternatives
au fur et à mesure on les enlève mais
tant qu'on n'a pas d'alternative et que
les autres pays européens ne le retirent
pas si la France seule les retire elle
se met une balle dans le pied c'est ce
qu'a fait madame Pompili sous François
Hollande avec cette loi qui interdit les
déodicotidoïdes je suis président
européen des agriculteurs il y a 10 pays
qui vont utiliser les néonicotinoïdes
pas nous et on importera leur sucre
c'est un comble je vais faire réagir
Nicolas Giraud sur cette question
justement dans ce contexte
d'affaiblissement de la souveraineté
alimentaire française et seront se tire
une balle dans le pied avec certaines
normes environnementales qui ne sont pas
respectées par les autres pays sur le
même marché moi je vais revenir sur deux
sujets les nicotinoïdes et l'eau le
premier sur les ninolécutinoïdes qu'on
s'entende bien si on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire parlons de
souveraineté alimentaire ne parlons pas
de balance commerciale c'est pas la même
chose la souveraineté alimentaire c'est
le droit des peuples le droit des pays a
émettre leur politique agricole et
alimentaire pour se nourrir dumping
c'est pas une logique d'exportation et
de faire des volumes donc si on veut
parler de la betterave et du sucre
ont même sans les néonicotinoïdes on
sera toujours souverain en sucre on est
une force exportatrice on est on utilise
également énormément de sucre pour
mettre dans nos voitures au travers de
l'éthanol à un moment donné ce qu'il
faut mettre des priorités si on lui
parlait souveraineté alimentaire mais
mettons des priorités on peut se passer
des nicotinoïdes tout en étant toujours
souverain en sucre faut arrêter de de
d'utiliser cette peur pour continuer à
garder ses produits là ça c'est la
première chose et la seconde sur
skyvoqué Cristiano Lambert sur l'eau on
est totalement d'accord qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire d'agriculture sans eau un
moment donné il faut remettre les choses
également dans leur contexte on ne peut
pas faire d'agriculture sans eau dans
les nappes phréatiques aujourd'hui
l'agriculture française c'est 6 à 7% de
sa surface agricole utile qui est
irriguée 93% de l'agriculture française
et non irriguée on pourrait appeler ça
l'agriculture plus qui bénéficie donc de
l'eau qui tombe et de l'eau qui a dans
les nappes pour faire pousser ses
cultures un moment donné on ne peut pas
basé une politique
étatique sur l'eau sur uniquement
l'irrigation et les réserves pour les
irrigants qui sont encore une minorité
il faudra des politiques pour eux mais
il faudra surtout une politique
d'ensemble pour l'ensemble de
l'agriculture qu'on a besoin d'accès à
l'eau François Patriat sur
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes
est-ce que l'interdiction de ces
produits phytosanitaires c'est énorme
environnemental ça ne pénalise pas au
final la France par rapport à ses
concurrents sur les marchés agricoles
alors sur les néons thyroïdes je suis
beaucoup plus mesuré parce que la
dangerosité réelle des néonicotinoïdes
en termes de santé humaine elle est
grande et les mesurée on la connaît et
on sait tous les dégâts qu'elle a fait
donc que tous les pays d'Europe et
l'Europe a voté aujourd'hui texte pour
dire qu'il allait les interdire le
problème c'est qu'il y a eu là encore
des gens qui ont dérogé au problème la
France utilise les néonicotinoïdes sur
la graine enrobée
nous prenons aujourd'hui en France les
gens d'exceptionnel à partir des
troupeaux allaitants et bien des animaux
qui vivent dans des pâtures qui
aménagent tout le territoire français
l'Auvergne le Massif Central la montagne
partout et là c'est beaucoup plus
coûteux et c'est vrai que devoir partir
mais nous avons pas réussi de voir
partir des broutards de notre pays qui
partent à 6 ou 8 mois qui partent en
Italie où il y a de le maïs dans
l'Italie du Nord pour revenir engraisser
transformer là la difficulté de là on a
pas réussi à trouver la transformation
moi j'ai essayé pendant des années en
région Bourgogne de faire des plans
d'engraissement pour qu'on a animaux on
engraisse des animaux sur place et qu'on
les consonnes sur place non pas qu'ils
aillent se faire ailleurs c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui parce que les
normes du marché et l'organisation des
producteurs n'étaient pas là niveau là 0
pour qu'on pour conclure on n'arrive pas
vraiment à localiser véritablement nos
productions nos élevages
on n'arrive pas totalement non aller
aller localiser mais on a aussi très
clairement un problème là je suis pas
d'accord avec un problème de
libre-échange à partir du moment où on
est dans une logique de libre-échange
surtout on se met également en
difficulté c'est c'est
excusez-moi je termine c'est le pays qui
arrivera le mieux à s'asseoir sur ses
droits sociaux et environnementaux qui
sera en capacité d'exportation on peut
apporter ou exporter des produits à
haute qualité le vin le fromage pourquoi
est-ce qu'on exporte du blé et qu'est-ce
qu'on exploite quand on export du blé
par exemple en France le blé qu'on
exporte c'est à peu près l'équivalent
des primes pack qui a sur ces surfaces
là est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'exporter nos prime pack voilà moi
c'est ça qu'on veut poser comme question
et on a d'autres productions à pouvoir
valoriser et à pouvoir exporter juste
une dernière chose vous vous parlez tout
à l'heure de de l'agriculture de
l'agriculture biologique j'aimerais bien
aussi en dire un mot
on est pour une fois en accord avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes de la
filière agricole autour de l'agriculture
biologique pour dire qu'il y a besoin de
la soutenir aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais
bien entendre le président et le
ministre de vous expliquer que il y aura
un soutien aux agriculteurs biologiques
pour qui continue à produire en
agriculture biologique qui est un
soutien à la trésorerie parce que c'est
ça dont on besoin beaucoup de paysannes
et de paysans sur ces filières là et
j'aimerais bien que Christiane Lambert
la FNSEA vous mettiez autant d'énergie à
aller chercher cette prime d'urgence
pour l'agriculture biologique ce que
vous l'avez fait pour les betteraviers
parce qu'à un moment donné on sait la
force que vous avez la capacité d'aller
chercher des budgets au ministère
allez-y pour l'agriculture biologique
pour conclure rapidement Christian
Lambert les syndicats agricoles peuvent
se retrouver autour du bio
ça me fait du bien quand Nicolas Giraud
dit à l'aide à l'aide vous êtes puissant
et des nous on a senti un communiqué de
presse il y a deux jours pour soutenir
les agriculteurs bio sur le blé moi je
peux pas entendre ce que me dit ce que
dit pardon monsieur Giraud produire du
blé pour l'exporter ça sert à rien
qu'est-ce qu'on dit à tous les Africains
quand t'as demandé qu'est-ce qu'on dit
au Maroc à la Tunisie à l'Égypte au
Liban à la Turquie qu'en plus venant de
Russie on leur dit mourrait de faim on
les aide à bâtir leur souveraineté
alimentaire
pardonisations qui le font mais faut
être sérieux il con
duit en bas de
côte mais ils n'arriveront pas à
produire tous leurs blé il le savent
pour commercer il faut commercer dans
les deux sens la France et le pays qui
importe plus que bien d'autres en
matière de fruits de légumes et de
produits exotiques donc on commet aussi
et notre blé il est attendu maintenant
je parle de souveraineté alimentaire
c'est pas l'échelle égoïste de la France
c'est à l'échelle de l'Union européenne
et c'est parce qu'il y a des pays du
monde qui de toute façon ont besoin de
ce que nous produisons et nous leur
achetons d'autres éléments et ce sera le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à cette
émission à ce premier plateau dans cette
première journée du Salon de
l'Agriculture une première journée et
bien où il y a le président de la
République dans sa visite traditionnelle
du salon le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron qui a rencontré les
éleveurs de la vache Ovalie l'égérie de
ce salon à cette année justement on va
retrouver Quentin calmer notre
journaliste qui est avec et bien
l'éleveuses d'Ovalie Quentin
mortier bonjour marine bonjour c'est
vous qui avez accueilli le présent
appuie que ce matin c'était un peu avant
8h au moment de l'inauguration du salon
comment ça s'est passé c'était
impressionnant comme maman oui bien sûr
ça s'est très bien passé c'était un
moment important on était heureux de
pouvoir rencontrer le président de la
République c'est un moment unique et
c'était l'occasion voilà de lui
présenter notre race notre vache et puis
lui parler des problématiques agricoles
pour toute la filière d'agriculture
française quoi c'est important on va la
voir cette vache aux valises vous avez
présenté au présent de la République une
vache salaire faut pas dire salaire faut
dire salaire elle a 5 ans et elle a
accompagné de ses deux petits
Utopia utopie dans le ring ici au milieu
du hall 1 lorsque vous avez échangé avec
Emmanuel Macron quel était votre message
à vous oui on est on lui a déjà fait
part de notre fierté de pouvoir
représenter l'agriculture française au
sens large d'être géré aujourd'hui avec
Ovalie et puis aussi on a souhaité
l'alerté sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui nous préoccupe nous les agriculteurs
et un petit peu tous qu'on soit éleveur
ou non les problèmes de sécheresse qu'on
arrête de manière récurrente tous les
ans et qui cette année s'annonce
régulièrement précoce et difficile pour
nous les sujets de rat au pied dans les
zones d'élevage qui sont dévastatrices
sur les exploitations avec des pertes de
fourrage qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 80%
donc pour nous c'est très très impactant
il y a aussi les accords du Mercosur qui
sont un sujet d'actualité prenant et qui
inquiète vraiment vraiment les éleveurs
quoi alors comment est-ce que vous avez
perçu lui son discours est-ce que vous
le trouvez à l'écoute du monde rural
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé lui de
son attitude par rapport à vous mais
nous on a été vraiment surpris il est
resté quand même pour moi un quart
d'heure avec nous il a pris le temps
d'échanger d'écouter nos messages de
devoir Ovalie il nous a posé plein de
questions sur notre race notre notre
exploitation voilà il était vraiment à
l'écoute très ouvert et ça a été quand
même un plaisir vraiment de pouvoir
échanger avec le président de la
République ce matin une frustration
quelque chose vous avez pas eu le temps
de lui dire et que vous voulez dire le
compte Public Sénat sur ce que vous
vivez vous dans le Puy-de-Dôme non enfin
oui on a pu échanger comme sur après
tous les sujets que je voulais voilà
dire après nous on a la chance d'élever
des salaires dans un département
magnifique le Puy-de-Dôme dans la région
Auvergne donc on nous c'est une
structure de montagne une petite
structure donc voilà c'était c'est
l'occasion de présenter ça on dit que la
vie des agriculteurs elle est dure il y
a pas de il y a pas de jours de congé
lorsqu'on est éleveur c'est 365 jours
sur 365 est-ce que vous portez aussi un
message d'espoir malgré la dureté de ce
métier aux jeunes générations ici au
salon est-ce que c'est ça aussi un de
vos objectifs oui tout à fait c'est même
un objectif que aujourd'hui est
primordial pour l'agriculture on efface
un souci de renouvellement de génération
on a une population d'agriculteurs qui
vieillissante des structures qui ne
seront pas reprises et aujourd'hui la
population agricole ne pourra pas se
suffire à elle-même il va falloir
attirer des jeunes extérieurs au milieu
agricole et pour ça c'est important nous
on est en cas de familiale avec mon mari
on a repris on est tous les deux des
citadins on a repris une exploitation
agricole hors quatre familles et on
souhaite vraiment pouvoir montrer aux
jeunes qui aujourd'hui souhaitent
pouvoir vivre du même métier que nous
c'est possible c'est de l'investissement
personnel financier c'est du temps mais
c'est merveilleux donc marine c'est le
premier jour du salon on voit qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup de monde dans des allées
comment ça se passe pour vous et pour
vos bêtes est-ce que vous êtes surpris
de ce monde est-ce que la vache réagit
bien oui oui on est très content il
y a vraiment des jumelles en plus c'est
magnifique donc on est très contents
c'est bienveillant c'est positif on est
vraiment dans quelque chose de dans la
bonne humeur c'est hyper agréable
elle est détendue voyez tout le monde
dort tout le monde se repose tout le
monde mange bien tout va bien merci
merci marine pour votre témoignage à
l'antenne de public serait donc voyez
beaucoup de monde dans les allées mais
tout se passe très bien autour de la
vache chez Jerry Alex merci beaucoup
Quentin on va continuer à parler des
enjeux de ce salon international de
l'agriculture avec mes invités
j'accueille sur ce plateau Arnaud
Gaillot bonjour vous êtes président du
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs j'accue
également Dominique charger bonjour
bonjour vous êtes président de la
coopération agricole qui représente les
coopératives agricoles et je précise que
vous êtes l'auteur du livre idées reçues
idée reçue sur les coopératives
agricoles aux éditions Le Cavalier Bleu
j'accue également Véronique Le Floch
bonjour bonjour vous êtes présidente
d'un autre syndicat agricole le syndicat
la Coordination rurale et puis
j'accueille Martin lévrier bonjour vous
êtes sénateur des Yvelines et membre du
groupe RDP au Sénat le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle Arnaud Gaillot
en tant que jeune président à des jeunes
agriculteurs puisque vous prenez vos
fonctions qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette visite du président de la
République vis-à-vis de la profession
nous ce qu'on attendait ce qu'on y a à
dire c'était de rassurer d'avoir le
courage politique de réaffirmer les
positions qui réaffirment depuis sa
prise de deuxième mandat et quand il
était venu à terre de Jim pour lancer la
pacte et la loi d'orientation et
dernière agricole c'est de réaffirmer
que ni plus ni moins avec la France
soutiendra ces agriculteurs et ses
agriculteurrices de réaffirmer que la
France ne laissera pas les agriculteurs
les agricultrices sans solution essaie
de réaffirmer que ben on va définir des
stratégies pour se dire que demain
l'avenir agricole et la souveraine
alimentaire existera encore en France
Dominique charger est-ce que vous êtes
optimiste optimiste sur cette avenir de
l'agriculture française alors qu'il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétudes on en parlait
avec les précédents invités sur la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France
oui absolument optimiste ton le reste et
on doit l'être mais effectivement on
doit quand même faire face à un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'on vit depuis
maintenant quelques années c'est celle
d'ailleurs qui était intervenus deux
fois à l'occasion enfin en tout cas en
même temps que salon de l'agriculture
c'est le covid en 2020 et puis la guerre
en Ukraine l'année dernière à peu près à
la même date et en fait ce sont des
événements qui ont considérablement
perturbé le fonctionnement de nos
marchés mais qui ont aussi fait prendre
confiance conscience à la société aux
citoyens et au monde politique de la
nécessité de travailler à cette
souveraineté alimentaire et qu'elle
n'était pas garantie donc c'est pour
nous l'occasion de ce salon faire passer
les messages aussi vers le président de
la République vers la société
l'historienne de manière générale de
cette nécessité d'avoir une production
agricole qui soit à la hauteur et en
capacité de nourrir les populations
Véronique Le Floch quel message la
coordination orale souhaite faire passer
au président de la République cette
année au salon alors là pour la
Coordination Rurale le message qu'on
souhaiterait passer au président de la
République
et celui d'agir pour mettre en place
toutes les conditions pour des
installations réussie pérenne avec donc
une agriculture qui soit viable vivable
et demain des exploitations
transmissibles donc c'est surtout de
mettre sur la table toutes les
conditions pour y arriver on ne demande
pas des soutiens financiers parce que on
ne demande pas être assisté on veut
produire et vivre de notre métier
effectivement il y a un vrai sujet
professionnel pour nos agriculteurs
Martin lévrier on est en plein débat
national en ce moment sur la réforme des
retraites et on voit que l'enjeu du côté
de l'agriculture c'est ne serait-ce que
le renouvellement de cette profession
absolument mais c'est une profession qui
souffre depuis plus de 20 ans
qu'on voit évoluer contre vents et
marées avec des politiques parfois très
compliquées des normes on en parlait
tout à l'heure parfois épouvantablement
contraignante et pour autant un monde
qui n'a cessé d'évoluer toujours au
service de Sa nations toujours au
service de ses citoyens et on l'oublie
et ce monde évoluant a fait que il y a
eu un gros bashing très fort pendant
très longtemps et très violent on
parlait des crises tout à l'heure ces
crises ont eu ce mérite de remettre
l'agriculture au centre de notre pays et
de remettre l'agriculteur au centre des
préoccupations des Français et même pas
je parle même pas de du besoin de
nourriture etc mais simplement
l'agriculteur redevient au centre des
procurations des Français et c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour autant on doit
répondre à une urgence et à des sujets
très importants l'important
effectivement c'est ce que vous abordiez
c'est comment transmettre comment
redonner l'envie à des jeunes
aujourd'hui d'être agriculteur comment
se poser la question de la transmission
des anciens vers les vers les ceux qui
veulent reprendre l'agriculture comment
former des grands sujets alors les
retraites c'est encore un autre sujet
qui qui n'a pas vraiment de lien pour
l'instant sur ce je trouve ici et
l'urgence c'est d'être en capacité de
dire aux agriculteurs aujourd'hui oui il
y a une crise il y a eu deux crises
terribles la crise la crise
effectivement vous l'avez dit du covid
la crise qui est plutôt qui est plutôt
une guerre d'ailleurs la guerre en
Ukraine qui nous impacte
considérablement
face à cette urgence est répondre être
capable de répondre sur le court terme
comment face aux urgences climatiques
qui sont elles aussi et urgentes et
importantes seront donc capables d'en
prendre la mesure aujourd'hui pour
préparer l'avenir et répondre à ce
besoin de long terme c'est tous ces
sujets là qui sont sur la table qui sont
essentiels mais qui sont je trouve
aujourd'hui à bordé autour d'une société
qui est plus optimiste auprès de cette
agriculteur qu'elle ne l'était il y a 20
ans qu'elle ne l'était il y a 10 ans
Arnaud Gaillot à cette question de la
transmission entre les générations
transmission des exploitations elle est
vraiment prégnante en ce moment pour les
agriculteurs c'est le vrai sujet de
demain enfin vous le disiez et c'est
quasiment 200 000 agriculteurs la moitié
des agriculteurs d'ici 10 ans qui vont
partir en retraite il faut qu'on se
doute d'un système de transmission dans
notre pays qui va garantir à nos aînés
de partir dignement retraite on a fait
et on s'est battu pour la revalorisation
des retraites et 25 meilleures années on
doit encore aller plus loin et
l'améliorer mais on doit mettre aussi
des outils en place pour que des jeunes
qui arrivent dans la profession ou moins
jeunes parce qu'on sait très bien a été
dit on sera pas en capacité de fournir
les remplacements rien que parce qu'on
connaît ou ce qu'on a en réserve dans
nos lycées donc on va accueillir des
gens en reconversion professionnelle des
gens d'autres univers et je pense que
plus on permettra une transmission en
douceur plus on permettra une
transmission avec des dispositifs
fiscaux qui permettent que des jeunes
reprennent des capitaux moins important
démarrage plus on aura des transmissions
réussie plus on aura des gens qui auront
envie de venir dans cette promotion
parce que derrière il faut aussi qu'on
donne des perspectives d'avenir ça a été
dit c'était dit sur les moyens de
production et à un moment donné vous
pouvez pas dire à des gens devenaient
des chefs d'entreprise mais vous savez
pas dans un an dans deux ans ou dans
trois ans vous serez je pense que les
jeunes ou moins jeunes qui vont venir
dans notre métier ont besoin de savoir
finalement c'est quoi la stratégie c'est
quoi la stratégie finalement de la ferme
France à horizon 2030 ce qu'on est en
train de faire finalement dans l'axe 3
de la du travail sur la paix loi de se
dire comment on s'adapte aux changements
et aux transitions agroécologiques et
climatiques on en est capable dans ce
pays-là si on se donne les moyens si on
investit dans la recherche si on se dit
qu'elle est dans 10 ans dans 15 ans on
veut arriver là mais le problème qui a
c'est que depuis 20 ans finalement on
attend de se prendre le mur en pleine
poire et de se dire aïs ça fait mal
comment on fait finalement pour pas le
reprendre une deuxième fois mais je
pense que là on est arrivé dans un vrai
moment où à force d'avoir laissé les
choses tarder à force d'avoir repoussé
sous le tapis et ben on se rend compte
que finalement on n'arrive pas trop à
tirer on n'a pas trop de gens qui ont
envie de reprendre notamment dans
l'élevage et moi qui vient de l'élevage
vous garantis que ça fait mal au cœur de
se dire que des gens fuient l'élevage
alors que c'est des métiers très nobles
très valorisants de travailler avec de
l'être vivant mais comme de travailler
avec du végétal enfin l'agriculture et
c'est l'enjeu de ce salon c'est qu'à
tous les concitoyens qui vont passer là
leur dire venez travailler dans les
métiers de l'agriculture parce que c'est
le plus beau métier du monde
l'agriculture c'est la première c'est le
premier des médicaments plus moment j'ai
ça moi vous avez de chances d'aller à
l'hôpital ah oui des métiers
passionnants mais Dominique charger on
n'a pas encore mis vraiment les
conditions pour attirer les jeunes vers
tes professions agricoles
vers du professeur agricole et je dirais
vers les métiers de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire parce qu'il y a
effectivement nos exploitations qui vont
devoir trouver des forces vives qu'on va
pas seulement l'épuiser effectivement au
sein des renouvellements familiaux mais
qui va falloir attirer venant d'autres
origines et qui va falloir
auxquels il va falloir apprendre ce
métier donc les les amener et puis
également aussi nos entreprises qui
fabriquent l'alimentation elles sont
indispensables elles sont sur les
territoires non coopératives il faudra
aussi que nous ayons des jeunes qui
viennent travailler pour que cette
production puisse être transformée en
alimentation effectivement les
conditions pour aujourd'hui attirer les
jeunes elles sont de plusieurs ordres il
y a effectivement
celle des compétences celle des
formations celle de la qualité du
travail dans nos métiers de diminuer la
pénibilité dans ce travail de faire en
sorte qu'on soit accompagné par plus de
robotique plus de modernisation qu'on
ait accès à plus de remplacement pour
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure ou
en tout cas c'était dit dans le
reportage on prend peu de vacances dans
ce métier il faut qu'on puisse prendre
plus de congés plus de vacances et puis
je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse pour l'ensemble de nos
métiers à la façon dont on va pouvoir
donner aux jeunes ce qu'ils attendent
aujourd'hui de du travail dans leur vie
et non plus le contraire de leur vie
dans le travail parce que les jeunes les
nouvelles générations demandent autre
chose la coopération agricole est en
train de faire aujourd'hui un tour de
France de consultation des jeunes de 15
à 30 ans dans lesquels nous les écoutons
sur ce que sont leurs perception et
leurs attentes de l'alimentation et de
l'agriculture d'une manière générale et
on voit bien
tu peux les attendre sont en train
d'évoluer radicalement par rapport à ce
que nous avons fait nous et par rapport
à la façon dont nous organisons
aujourd'hui nos métiers nos
professionnels donc il faut que nous
sachions faire des évolutions il faut
que nous sachions mettre de
l'investissement et il faut que tout ça
chiions apporter de nouvelles
considérations de nouvelles conceptions
de nos métiers pour que les jeunes
viennent travailler dans nos fermes et
dans nos entreprises allez on va
retrouver Quentin calmé qui sillonne les
allées du Salon de l'Agriculture et qui
a rencontré et bien une éleveuse qui
était qui a échangé avec Emmanuel Macron
et qui représente la race bovine des
rouges flamandes exactement alex je suis
avec Edith Mac bonjour Edith et on voit
une de vos vaches un juste derrière vous
il s'agit d'aurènes et donc
effectivement une vache de la race des
rouges flamandes et vous avez pu
échanger ce matin avec le président de
la République lorsqu'il déambulait ici
dans ce hall c'était quoi vous votre
message au président de la République
c'était simplement d'essayer de faire
part justement de notre race locale
parce que c'est vrai que la rouge
flamande donc en fait c'est une petite
population aujourd'hui
braceletière qui est dans les hauts de
France et le fait d'avoir pu voir le
président de la République c'était aussi
pouvoir lui dire qu'il est important de
préserver ces petits traces pour rester
dans une diversité il faut pas
uniformiser la production de lait en
France il faut qu'il y ait des cheptels
de races différentes c'est ça votre
message oui parce que aujourd'hui
combien savoir que si on a un beau
plateau de fromage en France c'est parce
qu'on a un nombre de races derrière ça
il y a un nombre d'éleveurs et
franchement l'élevage en France
aujourd'hui il faut faire beaucoup
d'efforts parce que c'est un métier qui
est même si on n'est passionné
aujourd'hui c'est des investissements
parfois lourds et avec une progression
des prix au niveau des matières
premières et tout ça on doit quand même
aujourd'hui vraiment être passionné et
aimer le métier
vous le disiez ça peut inquiéter aussi
les filières parce que il y a un
renouvellement de génération qui ne se
fait pas une bon niveau pour l'instant
et c'est un métier qui est très prenant
vous me l'avez dit 365 jours sur 365 ça
aussi c'est un message que vous auriez
aimé passer au présent de la République
oui parce que en fin de compte 365 jours
lui qui
d'ailleurs c'est difficile encore
aujourd'hui qu'avant ah oui c'est encore
plus difficile même si on a des
organismes qui s'en occupent vous savez
venir remplacer l'exploitant le samedi
et le dimanche c'est pas toujours
évident un mot édite pour évoquer aussi
un autre sujet qui me préoccupe aussi
les éleveurs c'est la sécheresse vous
nous le dites aussi dans les hauts de
France il y a des inquiétudes pour avoir
des peintures qui soit au niveau parce
que aussi c'est des cahiers des charges
ensuite pour votre laine n'est-ce pas
oui ben parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui on
nous pousse quand même de plus en plus à
vouloir produire un lait à base d'herbe
sauf qu'avec des sécheresses faut
pouvoir faire face et il est plus que
temps qu'on se préoccupe de pouvoir
faire des réserves d'eau parce que
aujourd'hui quand on doit par exemple
produire
de l'herbe sur une prairie et bien il
faut quand même des réserves en eau
quand on a vu les étés qu'on a pu avoir
les animaux il y a pas faut les nourrir
quoi et donc ça c'est quelque chose que
vous voyez dans votre département dans
votre région de Hauts-de-France
actuellement aussi il y a une sécheresse
des niveaux des nappes phréatiques qui
sont inquiétants oui oui de plus en plus
on s'en rend compte que il y a des il y
a même eu de toute façon on fait partie
des zones aussi où il y a eu des
restrictions on a quand même une zone
très je veux dire en polyculture élevage
donc plein de cultures on a la chance
d'avoir des terres très fertiles et donc
pour faire du légume aujourd'hui les
industries demandent d'arroser et on a
des agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui
malheureusement n'ont pas pu arroser
merci Edith un dernier mot il nous reste
quelques secondes mais un mot aussi sur
la transmission vous êtes professeur
également et qu'est-ce que ça nous dit
ici de tous ces jeunes qui s'occupent
des vaches et qui sont là pour en
prendre soin tout le long du salon c'est
quelque chose qui est important aussi
avec le journal et culture vous étonnez
oui bah moi je trouve qu'en fait c'est
une belle expérience pour les jeunes et
c'est vrai que j'avais la chance de
pouvoir emmener 3 de mes élèves au sein
de l'agriculture et c'est vrai que ils
en sont ravis et il faut aussi pouvoir
montrer que l'élevage même si parfois on
dit que c'est compliqué et bien il y a
encore des belles journées en
perspective et bien merci merci et
justement tous ces jeunes ils vont
emmener vos vaches maintenant c'est
l'heure de quoi de la traite voilà c'est
l'heure de la traite donc il va falloir
libérer les espaces Alex merci beaucoup
Quentin la présidente de la race Rouge
flamande Véronique Le Floch évoqué c'est
important de et bien
développer la diversité conservée en
tout cas à la diversité des races bovine
dans ce cas là en France quand on voit
ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron ce matin
c'est à dire que 70% de la viande
dans la restauration collective n'est
pas française on se dit que il y a
encore du boulot à mener pour valoriser
cette cette viande française tout à fait
et les producteurs sont en rendez-vous
les quantités sont produites on voit
bien justement la production en qui est
dessiné qui est exporté en vif avec une
balance commerciale qui dépasse les 1
milliard 5 et d'un autre côté une
balance commerciale en viande
fraîche et aussi congelé qui est faite
essentiellement de morceaux nobles et
qu'il a nous conduit avec un déficit
commercial de quelques centaines de
millions d'euros et qui se dégradent
alors bien même que en 2020 avec le
covid ça s'était amélioré non ça s'est
dégradé donc là il y a une stratégie de
filière qui n'est pas au rendez-vous et
tout simplement parce que les prix ne
sont pas en rendez-vous est-ce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier ce que les agriculteurs
travaillent soit avec des coopératives
soit avec des privés et que l'on n'a pas
réussi à obtenir s'est pris
rémunérateurs et tant que ces prix
rémunérateurs ne sont pas là le
développement et la transformation ne se
feront pas et là où il y a un hic c'est
que l'on voit nos industriels
coopératives comme privé se délocaliser
et investir à l'international et là on
se bosse beaucoup de questions pourquoi
ces investissements ne sont pas faits en
France pour justement assurer la
transformation d'un bout à l'autre pour
justement satisfaire cette souveraineté
alimentaire Martin lévrier comment vous
expliquer que même si on a de belles
filières agricoles françaises de belles
races bovine par exemple et bien les
produits français et la viande française
n'est pas assez consommée sur notre
territoire vous avez tout dit c'est
assez simple c'est effectivement avant
tout un problème de prix un problème
d'organisation
ce gouvernement a fait deux lois
égaleima et Gallim 2 travaillent sur le
regaling 3 une nouveauté malgré tout
c'est pour améliorer notamment le revenu
des agriculteurs premier point essentiel
mais derrière aussi là il est politique
ce cette chose là c'est que nous
évaluons les lois des Gallim 1 nous
avons vu qu'il y avait des problèmes
qu'elle ne résolvait pas tout loin de là
et Gallim 2 et c'est une c'est enfin le
rôle vrai du politique est aussi de
reprendre en main ce qu'il fait pour
l'évaluer et continuer à faire avancer
les choses et là on se rend bien on se
rend bien compte aujourd'hui que on a un
véritable problème du prix et qui vient
en particulier les distributeurs donc on
doit travailler ce sujet d'où et Galine
3 il faut vraiment le reprendre pour
avancer sur ce dossier on a un autre
sujet qui est moins abordé vous l'avez
dit que la transformation on parle de
proximité combien reste-t-il d'abattoirs
en France quelle est la capacité des
abattoirs français de traiter la viande
française la proximité c'est aussi ce
problème là et en France aujourd'hui on
doit reprendre ce chemin de la proximité
des outils de transformation que nous en
partie perdue qui sont dans les mains de
grosses très gros de très grosses
sociétés nous devons aussi reprendre ce
travail et c'est aussi par ce moyen là
une recréérons une productivité et une
compétitivité de nos produits en
particulier d'élevage Dominique chargé
comment on arrive à mettre plus de
proximité valoriser nos productions
locales c'est à l'état de mettre des
contraintes pour atteindre cet objectif
passer exactement le travail sur lequel
s'engage les coopératives dans la durée
les coopératives sont des outils
collectifs de territoire donc les outils
de transformation de collecte et de
transformation sont des outils qui
appartiennent aux agriculteurs et moi
j'ai voulu alerter ce matin le président
de la République sur le fait que le
déclin de la production agricole et là
vous l'avez dit 50% de la production ou
de la consommation de poulet en France
est importé 80% dans la restauration
collective en légumes de plein champ
nous importons aussi 50% fruits et
légumes 50% de ce que nous consommons
60% même j'ai cité aussi l'exemple du
sucre avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur les risques que nous avons par
rapport à la suppression d'une molécule
dont nous avons encore besoin pour faire
en sorte que les cultures soient
protégées nous allons avoir avec le
déclin de ces productions un très fort
risque de déclin de l'industrie les
entreprises ferment parce qu'il n'y a
plus de production et ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure par rapport au prix c'est
ce que vous avez repris nous avons
aujourd'hui une guerre des prix qui
sévit dans l'ensemble de la distribution
une distribution qui explique et
j'allais dire
on a expliqué depuis 20 ou 30 ans au
consommateur que l'alimentation n'était
pas cher n'avait pas de valeur on
faisait de la promotion à gogo et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ça nous a
conduit à importer une grande partie de
ce que nous consommons donc nous devons
reconquérir cette dynamique de
production et de transformation et pour
ça il faut effectivement que nous
supprimions les distorsions de
concurrence auxquelles nous devons faire
face c'est-à-dire que nous devons
pouvoir être valorisé pour les normes et
qualitatives de production que nous
avons en France et nous ne devons pas
accepter que des productions produites
dans des conditions différentes puissent
être importés en France pour venir dans
nos assiettes alors que nos produits
sont dans des normes plus exigeantes et
ne trouvent pas de place aujourd'hui sur
le commerce donc il y a un vrai problème
de normalisation il y a un vrai problème
de guerre des prix ayant fait un
problème un risque important de déclin
non seulement de la production mais
aussi de l'outil de transformation et
quand les outils de transformation fermé
comme le disait monsieur et bien il faut
beaucoup plus longtemps et en général on
ne les refait pas et la souveraineté
aliment a disparu à jamais donc c'est
important qu'on se pose maintenant la
question de notre souveraineté et de
notre capacité à reconquérir non
seulement la production mais aussi la
transformation de notre production sur
les territoires vous parliez de guerre
des prix qui explique le fait que ces
produits français ne sont pas assez
consommés Arnaud Gaillot malgré toutes
les lois notamment dans le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron pour et
bien favoriser la rémunération des
agriculteurs et bien le contenu est pas
notamment sur la valorisation de ces
produits
malheureusement le il faut pas décrier
la loi la loi a montré ses effets et je
pense qu'on l'a vu les prix ont monté
malheureusement c'est que on souffre de
choses on a eu le covid mais on a
surtout une guerre en Ukraine qui nous
fait exploser comme nos concitoyens nos
charges électriques nos charges de gaz
nos charges de fioul finalement tout ce
qu'on a donc finalement on a un peu cet
effet ciseaux qui est venu contre
caressa on a à l'heure actuelle une idée
qui a été commencée de germer par le
gouvernement mais pour l'instant qui
commence à s'arrêter ou nous on avait
marqué la prudence c'était sur l'idée du
panier anti-inflation ou du coup les
distributeurs et certains distributeurs
ont sorti ont pris de cours le
gouvernement en sortant leur liste
produit pas cher leur panier à moindre
coût et on se rend compte que ça a
déclenché finalement une guerre des prix
sans précédent parce que tu es la loi
egalims qu'elle oblige c'est de prendre
en compte la matière première agricole
mais les oblige pas en prendre en compte
finalement les hausses de charge dans
les entreprises qui sont le carton qui
sont l'énergie comme on l'a tous et ça
ça met en danger les groupes nous sommes
en danger les coopératifs ça met en
danger les PME et moi je partage qu'il y
en A10 c'est que oui il faut qu'on fasse
comprendre à nos concitoyens que
l'alimentation qu'on leur a fait croire
qui était la variable d'ajustement
pendant des années qui était à pas cher
qui était finalement qu'on trouvait
comme ça et ben oui elle a un coup parce
qu'elle a un coup derrière pour pouvoir
relever ses défis de transition elle a
un coût pour pouvoir relever le défi de
préserver l'environnement qui s'appelle
la planète Terre pour que demain nos
enfants nos petits-enfants puissent
continuer à y vivre et à faire les
métiers qu'il y a donc je je pense qu'on
a vraiment de grands enjeux mais on a
aussi et je le disais le président de la
République et là on a besoin aussi de
retrouver un courage politique qui
réaffirme en fait les valeurs dans ces
métiers là parce que ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est juste
mais voilà on a besoin de se finalement
de ce squash politique qui réaffie ça
parce que finalement quand on regarde à
l'heure actuelle dans ce pays les quatre
professions qui sont les piliers
indéfectible qui sont
l'alimentation qui sont la sécurité qui
sont la santé qui sont l'enseignement
c'est celle où ça souffre le plus c'est
celle où ça souffle le plus de
renouvellement ou c'est que les gens le
plus de mailles à aller posons-nous les
bonnes questions c'est qu'on les a trop
délaissés on les a trop mis de côté ou
qu'on a fait croire à tout le monde que
finalement vu qu'elles ont toujours
existé vu qu'elles ont toujours fait
partie de l'environnement elle risque
rien ben n'en forcer de constater que
elles sont un peu toutes en danger la
nôtre encore plus parce que derrière les
mots sur Renta alimentaire derrière les
mots à dire aux gens venaient travailler
dans ces beaux métiers là ben il y a
besoin d'acte et d'actes forts et vous
le disiez il est actuellement une hausse
du prix de l'al situation plus 12% en
2022 et ce matin Emmanuel Macron a lancé
un appel à aux enseignes de grandes
distribution pour qu'elle diminue leur
marge pour que et bien les consommateurs
soient gagnants et sont touchés au
revenu des agriculteurs on va écouter le
président de la République donc notre
alimentation on doit en préserver la
valeur pour que nos producteurs nos
agriculteurs ils vivent de ce revenu
distributeur on fasse très attention
parce qu'il y a certaines marques qui
sont pas assez de produits par nos
agriculteurs sont souvent des marques de
distributeur plutôt une envolée des prix
qui touche le portefeuille de nos
consommateurs donc faut faire cet effort
il faut être très vigilant mais là on a
besoin d'un effort collectif d'un
engagement c'est ça ce que je demande
aussi à nos distributeurs aujourd'hui
cette participer à l'effort ils font des
bénéfices des profits j'en suis heureux
pour eux et leurs salariés j'espère
qu'il le redistribue mais dans ce moment
là on peut pas demander un effort à nos
producteurs parce que nos agriculteurs
payent plus cher l'énergie il paye plus
cher les intrants divers produits et on
a besoin de garantir leurs revenus voilà
pour cette intervention du président de
la République convoi actuellement en
direct dans les allées du salon de
l'agriculture en échange avec les
Français c'est aussi ça le Salon
International de l'Agriculture aller à
la rencontre de nos éleveurs de nos
agriculteurs et puis aussi prendre des
bains de foule au Parc des Expositions
de la Porte de Versailles à Paris
Véronique Le Floch je voudrais vous
faire réagir sur ce qu'a dit le
président en la République
aussi aux grandes enseignes de
distribution de faire des efforts sur
les prix pour ne pas toucher les
agriculteurs et pour que les
consommateurs s'en sortent en période
d'inflation la distribution a surtout sa
propre stratégie qui vise à conserver
ses marges et ce qu'ils ont entrepris ce
qui négocie avec les industriels ce sont
bien
des hausses qui sont plus faibles sur
les MDD pour augmenter les marques leur
marque à eux si bien que on se retrouve
avec des hausse supérieurs sur les
marques nationales et sur les marques
producteurs qui du coup voit les volumes
diminués et là-dessus il y a c'est une
stratégie et ça va pas dans le bon sens
et c'est pour ça que nous avions
récemment manifesté à Carrefour pour
connaître justement la part consacrée au
MDD donc à ces marques distributeurs qui
enlèvent l'équipe par exemple
aujourd'hui représente plus de 55% de
leur vente donc on voit bien
explique qu'il maintienne leur marge par
le volume
Martin lévrier la balle est aussi dans
le camp de la grande distribution pour
diminuer un petit peu leur marge et que
tout le monde s'en sorte dans cette
période d'inflation elle était
évidemment dans les mains aussi de la
grande distribution on pourrait faire un
parallèle avec avec l'énergie sur
beaucoup de points on pourrait alors
j'ai pas comparer les bénéfices que ce
n'est pas du tout de la même valeur mais
quand des quand des sociétés des
entreprises arrivent à garder des marges
et faire des bénéfices en période de
crise il est assez naturel qu'un joue le
jeu quand on parle de souveraineté de
son pays qu'elle joue le jeu de ce que
doit faire son pays et je pense que les
grands distributeurs ont on démarche
suffisantes qui leur permettraient de
faire des efforts sur les prix pour
l'alimentation française et pour tous
les agriculteurs sur le même point on
peut aussi demander des efforts aux
Français
je reprends l'exemple de l'énergie on a
annoncé qu'il y avait peut-être
potentiellement des risques de coupure
d'électricité au mois de septembre au
mois d'octobre pour l'hiver les Français
ont fait un effort ont compris c'est en
baisser leur consommation
pas seulement d'énergie on est arrivé à
moins 10% bon pas que les Français c'est
plutôt 8% et l'industrie 10%. donc cet
effort ils sont capables de le faire au
même titre que je ne sais pas si vous le
savez mais à peu près 30 kg de
nourriture sont jetés par an par
français c'est des questions qu'on doit
se poser aussi c'est comment aujourd'hui
nous consommons mieux en peut être en
achetant un peu plus cher des produits
de meilleure qualité qui viennent de nos
producteurs en faisant que ce genre de
petits efforts sans que ça nous coûte
plus parce que finalement on est plus
économe sur d'autres sujets c'est le
deuxième parallèle que je voulais donner
et le dernier point qui touche aussi les
Français et nous tous c'est la valeur
travail on en a parlé plusieurs fois et
bien si on veut que si on veut que les
agriculteurs soit ce soit que qu'on
retrouve le plaisir de l'agriculture il
faut reconnaître la valeur travail
arrêtons de dire que le vrai travail
c'est de ne pas travailler le week-end
qu'il faut travailler que 35 heures par
semaine quand on est passionné on est
prêt à travailler 50 heures 60 heures
rappelons ça aux jeunes j'ai eu la
chance de m'occuper d'un centre de
formation dans mon ancienne vie des
sénateurs mais des jeunes qu'on
récupérait en échec scolaire qu'on a
amené au bac pro et qui découvrait le
métier de poissonnier pour ne pas le
nommer un jeune que j'ai récupéré qui
qui a découvert le métier de poissonnier
à 17 ans je pensais qu'il restait 15
jours dans son entreprise il y restait
les trois ans de sa formation il a eu
son bac pro avec mon son très bien 2 ans
après il racheté l'entreprise parce
qu'il a découvert la passion du travail
et comptait pas ses heures rappelons aux
Français le plaisir du travail et le
plaisir d'être agriculteur c'est un
métier extraordinaire parlons d'abord de
cela et on va retrouver un agriculteur
plus précisément un éleveur un éleveur
de race au bras qui a pu échanger avec
le président de la République Emmanuel
Macron et Quentin vous êtes avec lui
voilà on est avec lui on est avec Yves
Chassagny bonjour Yves c'était éleveur
président de cette filière Aubrac et
voyez Alex on est directement au milieu
de l'enclos vous avez le taureau juste
ici à la droite de Yves et derrière les
vaches Aubrac comme cela qui nous
regardent pendant cette interview
d'ailleurs vous avez pu vous entretenir
Yves avec le président de la République
c'était quoi vous votre message à
Emmanuel Macron nos messages d'abord sur
la richesse de la France avec toutes ces
races et particulièrement les rastocal
qui sont déjà habitués à des territoires
difficiles demain ces races sont des
véritables intérêts vis-à-vis du
changement climatique notamment il y
avait aussi un message sur
l'intergénérationnel l'importance encore
une fois des nouvelles générations voilà
vous connaissez les chiffres la moitié
des éleveurs qui vont partir en retraite
dans les 10 ans à venir donc ces Rasses
là aussi et sont sélectionnés pour
préparer vis-à-vis des attentes de
nouvelles générations et c'est un
témoignage que l'on a dans la bouche de
tous les éleveurs que l'on interviewé
depuis le début du salon on voulait vous
parler aussi de la sécheresse c'est une
problématique que vous avez dans votre
département vous aussi grosse
problématique de plus en plus prégnantes
au lieu de nouveaux très inquiets cette
année ce début d'année 2023 et là aussi
la génétique la sélection doit répondre
à des animaux plus résilients et vous
croyez que le bras par exemple peut être
une solution face au réchauffement
climatique ou c'est l'inverse l'Aubrac
de par son format modérée de par ses
habitudes à des territoires difficiles
semblent bien armés mais ça suffira pas
il faudra aussi inventer elle est une
dernière question avec vous sur un ses
échanges voilà avec des pays étrangers
sur ces accords commerciaux qui inquiète
on a vu que le Mercosur était en suspens
il y a d'autres échanges notamment avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande qui vont venir
inquiéter ça c'est une perte de
souveraineté alimentaire c'est grand
c'est grand traités commerciaux vous
voulez redouter vous alors d'abord les
albums sont déçus de leur demande
beaucoup d'efforts ils les font au
quotidien et puis de l'autre on voit que
nos produits sont bradés échangés contre
d'autres marchandises à chaque fois
c'est les éleveurs qui forment les
échanges ça c'est carrément pas
supportable qu'est-ce que les
problématiques avec ces accords de
libre-échange vous pouvez nous expliquer
ce que ça fait peser particulièrement
sur vos filières et bien d'un côté chez
nous des efforts des normes qui sont de
plus en plus de travailleurs des
produits d'excellence et puis à
l'inverse on laisse rentrer des produits
qui sont faits dans des conditions tout
à fait inacceptables avec des matières
souvent en quelques fois dangereuses ça
c'est pas entendre par exemple le bœuf
d'Argentine dont on connaît le goût etc
lui c'est quelque chose que vous
craignez en terme de concurrence par
exemple sur une aubra
bien entendu on est sur des coûts de
revient qui n'ont rien à voir avec ceux
de la France en plus on crée de la
déforestation on utilise des produits
hormonés ou autres qui sont tout à fait
inacceptables les éleveurs sont furieux
et donc sur ces accords de libre-échange
il nous reste auprès une minute
d'interview c'est l'accord de
libre-échange quel est votre message
vous à l'exécutif auprès de la
République mais je crois qu'en France on
n'a pas le droit si on avait pas les
produits qu'on connaît les races qu'on
connaît on pourrait l'entendre
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le droit de
laisser les éleveurs français à
l'abandon et de ne pas mettre en avant
l'excellence des produits français donc
il faudrait ne jamais ratifier des
accords tels que celui sur le Mercosur
qui est encore de négociation il a
entendu les éleveurs doivent être
protégées on leur demande des efforts
considérables et c'est pas derrière on
peut pas laisser brader les choses de
cette façon là et bien merci on a
entendu votre message au micro Public
Sénat voilà Alex pour cette colère qui
est gronde aussi chez les éleveurs merci
beaucoup Quentin de la colère des
inquiétudes notamment sur la question de
la sécheresse des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique avec une
période de sécheresse record en ce
moment Arnaud Gaillot c'est
l'agriculture et bien dans son entièreté
qui est frappé par un phénomène de
sécheresse à la fois les cultures et
puis l'élevage aussi oui malheureusement
ça ça ouvre des hospices 2023 pas très
réjouissante de ce côté là mais je pense
que ça confirme finalement ce qu'on dit
depuis longtemps sur nos capacités à
gérer l'eau à la stocker sa confirme
depuis longtemps ce qu'on demande aussi
sur la recherche et d'investir dans
finalement comment on trouve des plantes
qui résistent qui s'adaptent comment on
avance aussi sur la recherche génétique
comme c'était dit avec les races sont
les toucher Mike des croisements en
regardant un peu tout ça moi je pense
que ça remet vraiment encore une fois
s'il y en avait encore besoin les gens
face à la responsabilité qu'il faut se
poser bonne question parce que le débat
il est plus de savoir s'il y aura ou pas
un changement climatique il est acté et
on le sait très bien que ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui ça sera encore
différent demain en fait ce qu'il faut
c'est ramener de la pédagogie un peu de
pragmatisme arrêté les idéologies les
oppositions stériles et se dire que
l'eau il faut qu'on la gère toutes et
tous collectivement territoire par
territoire la question n'est pas de se
dire finalement comment on va irriguer
là ou comment ça en fait la première des
questions que tout le monde doit se
poser c'est est-ce que demain j'aurai
encore de l'eau quand je vais ouvrir mon
robinet elle est là la première question
de la gestion de l'eau et du stockage de
l'eau cette garantir que demain on a
encore une eau potable avant de se
partir dans des pragmatismes tout ça et
on le sait très bien qu'après suivant
les territoires suivant les capacités
qu'on a quand vous êtes dans des régions
comme la mienne où il y a des rivières
c'est ça va être une forme différente
que quand vous êtes dans la Vienne ou
tout ça et on le sait très bien que et
vous le demandez-le à tous des gens
sensés plutôt qu'à des faiseurs de peur
qui aiment bien agiter les choses que
plus vous stockez une masse importante
quand elle a l'air libre moins vous avez
ce phénomène d'évaporation qui vous fait
perdre trop de volume et il est là le
sujet et après
ce terme-là méga bassine parce que moi
dans les grandes réserves d'eau
linge à la machine à laver je stocke pas
de l'eau mais voilà c'est c'est des
réserves d'eau après est-ce que c'est
une grosse retenue qu'on a qu'on a fait
est-ce que c'est une retenue avec un
barrage sur un cours d'eau ou derrière
on va faire de l'énergie renouvelable
gaz au truc hydroélectrique enfin
laissons la main dans les territoires
avec les sénateurs avec les mers avec
les agriculteurs et les agriculteurs
Véronique Le Floch c'est grande réserves
d'eau méga bassines selon selon les
goûts c'est c'est une solution pour
justement lutter contre cette sécheresse
alors pour moi c'est pas le problème le
haut l'eau on y arrivera le problème ce
sont les prix si on avait les prix on
aurait la capacité d'avoir une année en
stock dans nos hangars dans nos cellules
de céréales on aurait une année à la
banque et on aurait une année en culture
et là les moyens sur l'eau on les
obtiendra de toute manière il y a un
retour à ce qui a eu existé par le passé
le problème c'est si nos politiques ne
prennent pas ce problème au bras le
corps on arrivera à ses accords de
libre-échange et là où Marc Reynaud
minimise le problème c'est qu'il dit que
les accords le ministre de l'Agriculture
ce n'est pas des échanges avec les pays
tiers c'est des échanges avec l'Europe
qui nous mettent à mal non le problème
il est autre parce que à partir du
moment où un pays européen importe
litière ensuite quand il démultiplie et
qu'ils partagent cette répartition de
produits importés il y a de nouveau la
perte de traçabilité parce que à partir
du moment où c'est sous une certaine
valeur ce n'est plus une importation en
partie d'un pays à partir d'un pays
tiers donc pour vous ces sujets c'est
surtout un sujet commercial et de marche
financière pour nos agriculteurs pour
faire face aux prises à l'avenir quand
même Dominique chargé est-ce qu'il y a
un sujet sur l'utilisation de l'eau
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé un plan de
sobriété sur cette ressource est-ce que
tout le monde quand même doit faire des
efforts pour mieux utiliser cette
ressource c'est évident c'est évident
qu'on doit tous et aussi les
périplements faire des efforts sur
l'efficacité dans l'utilisation de l'eau
en revanche nous avons besoin d'eau nous
ne pourrons pas faire d'agriculture sans
avoir à notre disposition de l'eau pour
pouvoir faire pousser les plantes au
moment où ils ont besoin d'eau est-ce
qu'on voit dans le changement climatique
qui est effectivement aujourd'hui acté
c'est des formes beaucoup plus
erratiques
depuis avec des moments très abondants
et des moments où on a plus d'eau
pendant un certain temps 30 jours sans
eau effectivement fin février pardon fin
janvier et le mois de février c'est
inédit ça veut dire qu'on doit apprendre
à gérer collectivement différemment
cette eau on doit d'ailleurs changer la
législation sur la réutilisation de
l'eau usée des eaux qui ont été traités
parce qu'aujourd'hui la législation nous
intervient servante de choses qui serait
qui devrait être qui pourrait être
possible donc il faut que nous sachions
collectivement faire évoluer les lois
mais sur le haut on a trois leviers on a
effectivement le levier de la recherche
et l'innovation qui doivent nous
nous apporter des plantes qui seront
plus résistantes au manque d'eau et
surtout à la canicule parce que la
sécheresse est une chose la canicule en
est une autre les températures
importantes que nous avons l'été la
deuxième c'est qu'effectivement nous
aurons besoin d'eau et la troisième
c'est que nous devons pouvoir gérer ces
risques et nous avons collectivement
travaillé
pour avoir un système d'assurance qui
puisse nous permettre aussi
collectivement d'assumer leur espace
parce que pour un agriculteur je pense
que c'est un petit peu ce qui a été dit
la difficulté d'ailleurs financière
technique et psychologique c'est de
pouvoir gérer et accepter son risque et
ce risque il doit être aujourd'hui pris
en charge en partie par des systèmes
d'assurance et aussi en cas de grande
sécheresse et de grandes catastrophes
par la collectivité parce que la
souveraineté alimentaire est un enjeu
collectif et vital Martin lévrier
finalement c'est un peu le même problème
que pour l'énergie ou l'alimentation
c'est un effort collectif de sobriété
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre chacun à sa
place mais oui c'est un effort collectif
et vous l'aviez très clairement les
assurances l'État doit être au
rendez-vous il a été sur ces dernières
crises si je parle de la crise à bière
dont on n'a pas parlé si si je parle
d'un certain nombre de crises qu'on a vu
ces dernières années l'État a toujours
été rendez-vous si on parle des
betteraves et de l'État est au
rendez-vous malgré tout et ça c'est
essentiel après chacun à sa place
effectivement quand on parle de je ne
vous suis pas complètement l'eau est un
véritable problème nous ne trompons pas
et dire qu'il y aura toujours de l'eau
peut-être mais peut-être pas du tout de
la même façon que nous l'utilisons
aujourd'hui et donc chacun doit être
aussi responsable de sa de sa gestion de
l'eau à tous les niveaux
les collectivités par exemple sur les
fuites enfin sur cette déperdition en
eau plus de 20% de départ d'édition en
eau sont l'ensemble des canalisations
que nous avons en France d'eau potable
donc il y a déjà été traité qui pour la
consommation que nous perdons
joyeusement parce que nous n'avons pas
entretenu pendant 40 ans 50 ans et
canalisations chaque pardon vous avez
l'air de chaque personne
doit prendre en main ce sujet là merci
beaucoup merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission pour cette
première journée au Salon International
de l'Agriculture on se retrouve lundi
lundi avec une émission ici en direct du
salon à 11h où on parlera justement des
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
sur notre agriculture très bonne fin de
journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est le rendez-vous
politique du week-end sur Public Sénat
autour de moi 4 invités qui viendront
débattre de l'actualité de la semaine il
me donneront les clés pour mieux
comprendre le monde dans lequel on vit
et se projeter sur les grands enjeux à
venir ils ne seront pas souvent d'accord
ils seront même souvent de mauvaise foi
mais je vous promets de l'intelligence
de l'humour et de l'originalité et
maintenant ce soir à 19h sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
faire un leg à la Fondation apprentie
d'Auteuil c'est permettre à des milliers
de jeunes de croire de nouveau en
l'avenir
[Musique]
France 24 et Public Sénat présente
j'ai décidé de lancer une opération
militaire spéciale
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre émission spéciale
sur France 24 et Public Sénat consacré à
l'Ukraine un an après l'invasion russe
du flan est du pays nous allons analyser
les enjeux géopolitiques de cette guerre
sous toutes les coutures en particulier
à travers le prisme européen le retour
d'une guerre de grande envergure aux
portes de lieu inquiète divise et
mobilise les 27 et dans cette émission
un nous tenterons d'analyser les causes
profondes du déclenchement de ce nouveau
conflit puis nous nous projeterons dans
la raison dans sa résolution et un futur
incertain et pour nous accompagner un
tout au long de ces débats un invité
spéciale Dominique de Villepin ancien
Premier ministre entre 2005 et 2007 et
également ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères durant la guerre en Irak vous
avez écrit plusieurs ouvrages dont
mémoire de paix pourtant de guerre sorti
chez Grassé en 2016 et qui semble
toujours d'actualité bonjour bonjour
Dominique de Villepin nous ouvrons sur
cette date anniversaire du 24 février
résonne dans toutes les mémoires la
vôtre en particulier
qu'est-ce que vous avez vécu ce jour-là
d'abord de la surprise d'autant plus que
les objectifs affichés par Moscou
semblait bien irréaliste vouloir
s'emparer non pas seulement
d'une partie supplémentaire du dombage
ou accroître ses positions dans le sud
mais s'emparer de toute l'Ukraine a
commencé par Kiev c'était une ambition
qui apparaissait tout à fait contraire
aux intérêts même de la Russie dans la
durée
alors on part justement tout de suite
direction qui a fait un retrouver
ludmilab du mystère qui est député au
parlement
ukrainien la Rada vous êtes également en
ludmi la mère de deux enfants et depuis
le début des combats vous avez rejoint
le front qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé à
prendre les armes pour la première fois
bonjour en fait c'était une décision la
plus facile je pense de ma vie parce que
quand la guerre a commencé dans le
centre ville de Kiev avec des attaques
missiles le 24 février il y avait pas de
question que c'est
l'obligation de tous les Ukrainiens de
défendre notre pays notre liberté et
notre choix européen parce que c'est
bien évidemment et c'était déclaré par
Moscou plusieurs fois que le but
principal de cette guerre c'est de ne
pas laisser l'Ukraine intégrire avec
l'Union européenne continuer la ville
dans la famille des pays démocratiques
et civilisés toutes le pays tout le
peuple craignant maintenant après les
armes et continuent à être très fort
comment réagir à ce témoignage de
l'héroïsme ordinaire des Ukrainiens
auxquels on s'entendait pas forcément
non plus
oui tout à fait il y a une résistance à
la fois bien sûr des dirigeants
Ukrainiens mais du peuple ukrainien qui
est tout à fait remarquable et qui a
étonné partout à travers le monde a
commencé par Vladimir Poutine lui-même
jamais il n'a imaginé que l'Ukraine
puisse résister à ce point-là il pensait
en quelques jours pouvoir s'emparer du
pays et faire partie ce qui dirigeaient
l'Ukraine et il a aujourd'hui forcé de
constater qu'il y a une réalité du
peuple ukrainien qui s'est sans doute
considérablement renforcé durant cette
guerre alors une année qui a changé la
face de l'Europe et toute sa pensée
géopolitique un an de guerre de réaction
de sanctions de tension résumer en
images par famille Ricard
les événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'Europe et
de notre pays
[Musique]
nous sommes prêts à prendre de nouvelles
sanctions plus sévères si Poutine ne
revient pas en arrière et arrêtent la
guerre qu'il a initié
ici c'est bien organisé pour les enfants
la nourriture
mais nous espérons pouvoir retourner en
Ukraine le plus vite possible c'est
notre pays notre maison toute notre vie
est là-bas
[Musique]
de soutien pour parler à la fois du
présent et de l'avenir
en décidant aujourd'hui d'accorder le
statut de candidat à l'Ukraine c'est un
message très fort
il ne s'agit pas de 5 ou 10 ou 15 chars
les besoins sont plus importants nous
faisons chaque jour le nécessaire pour
combler le déficit et je remercie tous
ceux qui nous soutiennent dans cette
démarche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Dominique de Villepin l'Europe aussi a
été prise de cours et en particulier à
l'ouest par rapport au pays de l'Est qui
nous avait alerté véritablement sur le
danger de cette Russie de Vladimir
Poutine c'est vrai qu'il y a
sans doute des regards différents entre
les pays voisins de la Russie qui ont
une expérience historique qui constitue
un véritable traumatisme par rapport à
la Russie et les autres pays de l'ouest
de l'Europe et en particulier la France
et l'Allemagne qui perçoivent la Russie
davantage comme une grande puissance et
évidemment qui sont sensibles à la
politique menée par la Russie que ce
soit au Moyen-Orient depuis 2015 que ce
soit aujourd'hui en Afrique ou en Asie
centrale donc ces deux perceptions
différentes mais je pense que ces deux
regards sont utiles et seront encore
plus utiles aux mamans où il nous faudra
repenser l'avenir de la Russie dans le
cadre de l'Europe alors on peut on peut
considérer que nous n'avons pas
peut-être été suffisamment fort dans la
décision concernant les sanctions au
début mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
cap est clairement fixé et cette unité
est clairement affirmée c'est bien
l'objectif qui doit être le nôtre alors
Dominique de Villepin je vous propose de
prendre la direction de l'Allemagne
direction Cologne exactement nous nous
retrouvons Daniel freuder allemand vert
Daniel freneux votre pays avait des
relations privilégiées avec Moscou avec
une dépendance au gaz russe extrêmement
forte tout en ayant une doctrine
absolument pacifiste ce 24 février 2022
il est jour les mois qui ont suivi ont
ébranlé toutes ces certitudes dans votre
pays
oui je pense nous en tant que verre en a
longtemps critiqué la dépendance du gaz
russe ou si la construction par exemple
de notes stream mais pour une bonne
partie de la politique allemande c'était
absolument
normal de créer cette dépendance et de
vouloir la continuer je pense à changer
on a montré qu'une dépendance qui était
à 50% au niveau gaz mais aussi sur le
charbon sur le pétrole aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne n’importe rien du tout de la
Russie pour les énergies fossiles on a
on a pu redirigérer
nos importations donc je pense ça c'est
une un grand succès que nous en a montré
au gouvernement ces derniers mois mais
aussi d'accroître le support surtout
aussi militaire pour pour l'Ukraine je
suis très content que maintenant en
support nos amis Ukrainiens aussi avec
des
ça a été un long débat mais on y est
finalement
un grand changement là sur cette
doctrine militaire en Allemagne c'est
vraiment un bouleversement des 50
dernières années passées
[Musique]
vous pouvez très changer finalement
depuis un an il y a une évolution qui se
fait à travers le conflit le fond de 100
milliards qui a été décidé montre bien
cette volonté aujourd'hui de réarmer et
d'apporter une contribution il souhaite
même apporter la première des
contributions en Europe constatons
néanmoins que cet effort se fait surtout
dans le cadre de l'OTAN et et
qu'aujourd'hui le pilier européen de la
défense reste encore très faible dans le
cadre de l'Europe et donc l'ambition
française défendue par le président
Macron de souveraineté européenne
d'autonomie stratégique ne rencontre
malheureusement pas suffisamment d'écho
d'une du côté de nos partenaires
européens et pourtant il est bien
important
d'avoir en tête le risque constitue pour
nous
[Musique]
cette accroissement des menaces
sécuritaires l'Amérique ne sera pas
toujours là pour nous protéger une
évolution lors de la prochaine
présidentielle est possible l'évolution
de la nouvelle Chambre des Représentants
est possible qui pourraient décider de
limiter le soutien à l'Ukraine et donc
l'Europe doit se prendre en main
l'Europe doit s'affirmer davantage et
les projets que nous avons avec
l'Allemagne sur le projet d'avion du
futur de char franco-allemand
sont absolument indispensables et donc
je suis heureux de voir que dans le
discours de Olaf Scholl ça Munich il y a
un esprit de conciliation on l'a vu en
particulier en ce qui concerne le
bouclier antimissiles que souhaite les
Allemands avec 14 autres pays européens
donc il y a là une réflexion qui avance
mais soyons bien conscients que il est
essentiel que ce sursaut européen se
confirme et marque bien la capacité
d'indépendance de l'Europe de Villepin
je vous pose de repartir pour Kiev
retrouver Ludmila du mystère député
ukrainienne votre pays le Milan très
jeune démocratie c'est résolument tourné
vers l'Europe en 2014 post-révolution my
dan qu'est-ce qui il a rendu si si
résistant et s'y préparer
pour nous la guerre a commencé par le 24
février mais en 2014 avec l'annexion de
Crimée et l'occupation de
d'une partie de danse et on a commencé à
ce moment-là de développer notre armée
et c'est le peuple craignant qui forme
l'armée maintenant parce que c'est le
peuple craignant qui a pris les armes et
c'est les volontaires qui ont commencé à
lutter contre ce Malte elle était
depuis 2014 on a fait beaucoup pour
s'intégrer avec le temps pour traîner
nos militaires